welcome to this data engineering crash
course created by Justin Chow this
course covers the essentials of data
engineering you'll learn about databases
Docker and analytical engineering you'll
explore Advanced topics like data
pipeline building with airflow and
you'll engage in batch processing with
spark and streaming data with Kafka the
course culminates in a comprehensive
project putting your skills to the test
in creating a full end to-end pipeline
hey everyone welcome to the course my
name is Justin Chow I'm a developer
Advocate at airbit I'm going to be going
through kind of essentially what you
need to know in order to become a data
engineer what goes into Data engineering
and then this is going to go into a
fully fledged demo where you can follow
me in creating a data pipeline from
scratch and then evolving that into a
fully fledged data pipeline using
open-source tools such as air bites so
hopefully you enjoyed this and this
gathers some interest if anything along
with data engineering or software
engineering in general is of interest to
you then this should be good good to
know but without further Ado let's get
into the course so we're looking over
the introduction to data engineering but
you may be thinking why data Engineering
in the first place well there's a couple
reasons why you may want to consider
getting into Data engineering first
there's a high failure rate of Big Data
projects and the percentage there based
off of the data that we've collected is
85 to 87% of those projects failing and
obviously as I've said that's pretty
pretty high those failures are due to
unreliable data infrastructures and
quality data in the past there's been an
expectations for data scientists to
build out that data infrastructure
that's necessary for those projects with
the infrastructure that was put in place
there's always incorrect data modeling
and redundant work that they have to do
because of the incorrect data modeling
and the Redundant work that they have to
do there's a high rate of data scientist
turnover so there's a high need of data
Engineers to process that data and
extract value instead of the data
scientists with all of that being said
there is a growing importance of the
data engineering role as we speak if
we're talking compensation right now in
the US the average median salary for
data Engineers is 90 to 150k a year and
obviously I say in the US it still
highly depends on the location and
whether you're in the states or not so
that number will change now let's look
at the business potential and impact
that data Engineers can have in any
company you will have a crucial role in
the success of making data driven
decisions in the AI and ml space for
applications espec especially with the
rise of chat GPT right now and the AI
space in general data Engineers are
going to have that crucial role in
determining what happens with those
applications and the data in general now
let's look at the business potential
that you have as data engineers and the
impact you can make in any company that
you work for the first one being is that
you're going to have a crucial role in
the success of making data driven
decisions in the AI and ml space for
applications and so with the rise of
chat GPT and the AI space you're going
to be a crucial factor in that aspect
and for any company that wants to and
should be getting into AI in general the
next thing you're going to be doing is
ensuring that there's efficient
management and processing of the actual
data as it moves Downstream while it
moves Downstream you're also ensuring
that the data quality the security and
availability of it to those teams
Downstream such as the data scientists
the data analysts or any other team that
has to work with data in your company
that it's quality it's secure it's
formatted the way that they need it and
it's never not flowing Downstream this
will also lead to better insights and
outcomes for your company and overall
just drive Innovation and
competitiveness so that your company can
Thrive and that your team can Thrive so
now we're moving on into the first
module which is the introduction to
Docker and what we use Docker for in
data engineering but first we have to
have a better understanding of what it
is if you haven't used it before Docker
is an open source platform that
simplifies the process of building
shipping and running any applications
inside containers so imagine IM you are
working on a project and you want your
co-workers to try and use it to see if
there's any issues but they can't run it
for some reason and you kind of run into
that good old saying of hey it runs okay
on my machine well what Docker is able
to do is you're able to put your
environment into a container and that
container will include every dependency
and kind of Silo everything into again
this container which you can then pass
on to your co-workers or even run up in
the cloud to have your application
running as it was when you were
developing it so it essentially just
helps organize and make sure everything
works as developed so if we're going
over containers and their benefits
containers are lightweight portable and
self-sufficient environments that
package an application along with all
its dependencies libraries and
configurations as I mentioned before
again just going over how much Docker
has really really helped engineers in
General on packaging their their
applications to make sure that they
don't run into any issues down the line
when testing and developing and to make
sure that those environments are
reproducible in case anything goes wrong
and making sure that also when they're
pushing up into the cloud or into
production that those applications are
working as intended and when they were
testing it's going to work the same way
in prod so now just imagine that all
your apps code and all your apps
dependencies are landing into one of
these containers and you're shipping one
of those off out into you know your
co-worker place or on AWS or gcp
everything that was inside that
container will be seen on the other end
as well now as I mentioned before in
software development we're looking at
Docker in the form of testing deployment
for its ease of use speed and
flexibility it assists with the
deployment scaling and management of
those applications using what we call
containerization which is just a
lightweight form of virtualization so if
you look on the right hand side's
illustration here you can see that we
have a couple apps that are in
containers using Docker uh as well as
you know sitting on top of your oper in
system and the infrastructure and it's
all running all within the docker
ecosystem now there are three main
concepts with Docker that we need to
understand the first one is going to be
Docker files the second one is going to
be Docker images and the third one is
going to be Docker containers now let's
go over what those three are right now
the first step is the docker file the
docker file is a text file that consists
of all the instructions needed hence
blueprints that we want Docker to use
all in order to create the docker image
so the docker image is what is created
from the docker file hence the blueprint
so the blueprint then creates our Docker
image which is the lightweight
Standalone executable package that
includes everything we need to run your
piece of software that includes code the
runtime libraries environment variables
and config files the one thing to note
is that images are readon and immutable
so nothing can change within the docker
image itself if you wanted to create
another Docker image or modify anything
that exists you want to modify your
Docker file and the instructions that
are inside that text file to create a
new Docker image so that's why we stick
the image into a Docker container which
is the runtime instance of our Docker
image or in other words the running
version of the image is the docker
container this Docker container is
completely isolated from the host and
other containers that you may have
running it has its own file system and
can be started stopped and deleted
independently so for example we may have
one Docker image that contains our
application but we have three different
Docker containers running that same
image so we have three different
environments three different instances
of that image but I can stop one and the
other two are still going to run I can
delete one and nothing changes in those
other containers because they are
isolated environments and you can run
tests you can do anything you want in
those containers but nothing will change
unless it is done inside the container
so first things first to get started
with Docker is obviously we're going to
want to install Docker so head over to
doer. and here is the landing page of
Docker now what we want to do is simply
just download Docker for whatever
operating system you have I am currently
running on a mac Apple chip so I would
click this and download Docker desktop
which also comes with Docker compose
which we will also need for later along
in this course but just know that Docker
compose and Docker desktop are two
prerequisites to running with Docker
right now now if you're on Windows
obviously follow the instructions for
Windows if you're on Linux follow the
instructions for Linux but go ahead and
download Docker for your machine and if
you have any questions uh you can also
go over to Docker and they have a really
good explanation in their docs on how to
install Docker desktop for your machine
and get going with that so make sure you
do this first now that we have Docker
installed I think the docker docks have
a great getting started guide on how you
can actually containerize an application
and so what we're going to do is
actually just go through this really
quick and it can give us a great idea of
how to containerize an application
through a Docker file how we build the
image getting the image to run inside of
a container and then a couple other
things like networking and things like
that so let's go ahead and go through
the getting started guide and then we'll
move on into the SQL module right after
so if you were still confused on what a
container is or what an image is it
gives you a good rundown here at the
beginning of part one but let's go into
part two on how we can containerize an
application first things first is they
actually have a getting started app
which is just a to-do app for you to
containerize but what we're going to do
first is simply just clone this and and
use it for the rest of this guide I'm
going to open up my terminal here and
make a directory and I'm going to call
this Docker tutorial now I'm going to CD
into Docker
tutorial and after that what we're going
to do is paste in the command that was
in there which simply just clones the
repo and obviously if it wasn't clear
enough and make sure you have a text
editor installed I'm using vs code and I
think that should be it obviously Docker
installed now that it's Clon let's go
ahead and CD into the getting started
guide and what we can see here is if we
open up vs code there's a couple things
here so we have a spec file we only
really need to look at the source file
but this is just a simple to-do app so
let's go ahead and go back to the
getting started guide and it has the
instructions for you on Mac and windows
so depending on your operating system
make sure you follow the right ones but
we've already cded into it what we're
going to do is inside of the route
directory of the getting started app
we're going going to create a Docker
file and as mentioned before this is
going to be the instructions on how we
build the image that containerize the
application that the docker file is
sitting in so now that I've created the
docker file if type in LS you can see
that the docker file is there so what
we're going to do is they've provided us
the instructions or the contents that
we're going to use for this Docker file
now you can see that we have a couple
things here that we haven't seen before
but essentially what from is is we're
going to use the node 18 package that
we're pulling from the docker Hub to run
our environment in or our run time the
working directory is going to be in the
SL app or the root directory of the
application this simply copies
everything and then we're going to run
this command which is yarn install
production other commands that are going
to be is going to be node and we're
going to look at in the source index.js
file and we're also exposing Port 3000
so you can see that these instructions
are pretty straightforward read like
English the one thing to take in mind is
that this does does have to be in order
this cannot be misplaced so keep that in
mind when you're writing your own Docker
files but what we're going to do is
we're simply just going to copy this
switch back over to our vs code head
into Docker file and then just paste
this in and save now that that's saved
they give us a command so we're going to
run Docker build hyphen T which simply
just tags our image and then we're going
to name it getting started so that will
be the name of our image and then the
dot we need at the end to tell Docker
where to look for everything to
containerize which will simply just be
in the current directory so I'm going to
go ahead and copy this command as well
paste this in also make sure that you
have the docker Damon running if you
install doer desktop just simply open
the application let everything launch
and then you should be good so I'm going
to go ahead and hit enter this is going
to do a couple things awesome so now if
we go back into Docker desktop and we go
into images you can see at the very top
getting started is created we have an
image the tag is going to be the latest
tag hasn't been used yet tells us our
size but now we have an image with
everything as you can see from the
docker file so you can see the commands
that we ran we have node version 18
which we did with the from command and
then we're also exposing Port 3000 so
you can see that the docker files
blueprint is in play here next thing
we're going to do is going to start this
container so we can say Docker run which
is going to run the image in a container
we're going to flag it for DP which the
D flag is short for detach which runs
the container in the background the P
flag is short for publish which means
that we're creating the this port
mapping so that we can actually access
this container locally and with the
mapping we're pointing it to a local
host here so 12.0.0 point1 and we're
opening it on Port 3000 now keep in mind
this can change say you have an
application already running on Port
3,000 but you wanted to run this on Port
6000 you can definitely change this but
this number after the colon needs to
stay at 3,000 because in our Docker file
we exposed Port 3000 so to be able to
access this we need to still keep that
number to 3,000 and then after this this
is the name of our container so
obviously we're going to name it getting
started so let me copy and paste this go
back in our terminal and as you can see
it spits out a container ID uh I'm going
to go ah and copy this for later but if
we go back into Docker desktop now just
for a simpler gooey to see if we go to
the containers tab you can see that a
container was created with the image
getting started and it is currently
running on Port 3000 so now if we're
going to go back here and we want to go
to Local Host Port 3000 you can see that
the app is now running locally and we're
accessing this container so that is good
now we can move on well first of all
what we may want to do is I can show you
guys that you can actually write stuff
to this so as I mentioned before this is
a to-do app so I can say get cat food
take out the trash very simple react app
going on right now that is inside of a
container so as I mentioned previously
before we started this demo is that
Docker contains a runtime it contains
all the environment variables and it
contains every single dependency that
react or this application in general
needs in order to run and so we're
siloed inside of a container with a
runtime with this environment and we're
able to actually use the application
within the container there's a couple
other commands that tells us so in the
command line we can run Docker PS and it
will name any other containers that are
currently running along with their
container ID so as I mentioned this
container ID popped up but if I type in
Docker PS it's going to be the only one
running but if there were any other
containers running we can pull their
container ID along with their names and
other information the other thing to
note too is that container IDs can be
accessed you don't need the full
container ID you only need the first
couple digits here and you can still
access that container so let's move on
to part three here now we were going to
want to make some changes to this code
and this is going to show us how
updating the application itself changes
things so they want us to change a
paragraph inside of the SRC static JS
app.js file so let's head back into into
vs code so we're in SRC we're in static
we're going to go to
index.js JS app.js sorry and then go to
56 and then we're simply going to change
this text to be what they told us we're
going to go ahead and save that but now
that we've updated the application that
means we actually have to build another
version of this image because the image
we built cannot be Rewritten it is
completely readon and so if we're going
to make any changes we have to create
another image and so that's exactly what
we're going to do we're going to run the
same Docker build command in the
terminal and that's going to build
another image and so now what we're
going to do is we're going to run
container command but we're going to get
an error here because we already have a
container with that name that's binded
to Port 3000 now if we want to remove
the old container that this will bring
us back into Docker PS so we're going to
run Docker PS and so we can see that
this container is still running so what
we're going to do is we're going to say
Docker RM paste the container ID and
that should give me another error saying
you cannot remove a running container so
we going to say Docker RM and put in the
F flag that will stop the container as
well as remove the container so I'm
going to do that and that should now get
rid of it and now we can see that this
has stopped and we can copy and paste
this again and now we've created another
container and it has started running
with the updated image now if we go back
into the to-do app and refresh this you
can see that it's completely fresh and
the new text has been added so that's
what happen happens when you go and
update an application we're going to
skip part four but if you wanted to push
this image up into the docker hub for
other people to access you can
absolutely do that we're not doing that
right now so at your own you can go
through part four but we're going to go
to part five and this is actually a big
one because sometimes we're messing with
data and as we saw in the to-do app we
have data and we want to persist it but
if we were to stop the container and
open it the data that we had previously
is going to be gone so the way we can
actually persist data is by simply
adding a couple things so we're going to
go through the steps one more time but
we're going to run this command here
we're simply going to start a container
that has a buntu running and it's going
to contain a file called data. text that
will have a random number between 1 and
10,000 so let's go open up my terminal
and we're going to run Docker through
that and as you can see it created
another container has an image of auntu
I already had it installed locally but
if you do not have the auntu image it
will immediately detect that and
download that from the docker Hub once
we have that going we're going to copy
and paste this and this will simply
check the file that is inside the
container which is data. text and it
should spit out the name of the or
should not spit out the name but it
should spit out the number and what we
need to do is we need to remove the
current container ID or the placeholder
there with the actual container ID and
there we go we have 848 that's spit out
to us so we know that there is data
inside they want us to start another
container that has a buntu so we're
going to go ahead and do that as well
and it'll list in every single folder
that is currently in the root of that
container and then what we're going to
do also is we're going to remove that
first container so again we're going to
go Docker
RMF and then the first container should
be this one right here so we went ahead
and remove that so the way to process
data in that container is going to be by
creating a volume and it's pretty simple
to do so the first thing we're going to
do is run this Command right here that
they give us essentially we're going to
be creating a volume called Todo hyen DB
so let me go ahead and open my terminal
here and what we're going to see in the
volumes tab now is a to do hyphen DB
what we're going to have to do is remove
the container that we created because it
is running without a persistent volume
because we created the volume after
container creation so we're going to
have to create a fresh one so again let
me grab grab the container ID of the
getting started container and same thing
Docker RM hyphen f and with the
container ID and that should remove it
for other purposes let me also just
remove this as well cool so we have a
clean slate now we're simply going to
copy this command but there's a couple
things here so along with the run and
run command the dnp flags as well as
mounting this or not mounting this but
binding it to the port 3000 we're also
mounting the volume here which is going
to be the flag here that we see or the
option and we're specifying the volume
that we want to mount so the type is
going to be volume the source of the
volume is going to be the to-do hyphen
DB volume we just created and the target
is going to be where the actual data
sits inside of the container so that is
the path that we're going to do and then
getting started we're actually just
specifying the image that we what we're
using or the container so let me go
ahead and copy this command paste it in
and now you can see that we have another
container with getting started and it
will be utilizing the 2db volume that
we've created so now what we can do
since it's running we're going to go
back here to the to-do app and as you
can see I have some data that was in
there and I didn't add anything you saw
that it was empty and there's two tasks
in here that I added previously about I
mean yesterday and they persisted so now
we're able to tap into the volume and
the data and anything that we do from
here on out let's just say I I don't
know go to the gym we want to add that
if we stop this container and then start
it again and refresh this we can see
that the data is persisting now so
volume creation is going to be the way
to persist databases especially if
you're testing stuff this is a good way
to do that within Docker and it's easy
to play around with servers and actual
databases now that we have data that
persists instead of having to reload and
add more data over and over and over
again so there's a couple other things
that we can see but if you were to run
Docker volume inspect on the volume
itself you can see a couple things of
metadata here but specifically we get to
see the mount point the name the scope
of it and it's created time so those are
a cool couple things if you want to
persist databases within Docker next
thing we're going to do is we're going
to skip over to part seven I don't
really want to touch into the used bind
mounts right now but multicontainer apps
so as I mentioned we may have a couple
things that we're running and so
multiple containers are going to be
needed in this case we have our to-do
app but we also want to create a MySQL
container that runs in tandem with the
to-do app so that we can isolate our
database and our front end app here in
order for these two containers to talk
we're going to need to create a network
and that's exactly what we're going to
do right now so we're going to run this
command Docker Network create and the
Network's name is going to be to-do app
so let me go ahead and run that right
now it's going to give me an error
because I already created this but go
ahead and run that and it will create a
network there for you so now what we're
doing is we're going to create a another
container and then attach it to the
network that we just created and so you
can see that we have a couple Flags here
first ones are going to be the network
so we're tying the network of this
container to the to-do app Network we
created the Alias of this is going to be
my SQL so when we see the container
through the network we're going to know
that this container here is the MySQL
container some of the variables that we
have here are going to be the volume
that we want to create is going to be
the to-do my SQL hyphen data volume so
we're creating a volume there to persist
the actual database and then we have two
environment Flags specific to my SQL
again if you're using something like
maybe say postgress there's going to be
some different environment variables you
need to attach to this container two of
the first ones being in my SQL are going
to be the root password as well as the
database name so we know that our
password Here is secret and then the
name of our database is going to be
to-dos and we're going to be pulling the
MySQL version 8 Docker image so what
we're going to do is copy this over and
we're going to go into our terminal and
create that and now we can see we have a
MySQL image again I've downloaded
locally already and the container is now
running to confirm that we have the
database running we're going to run this
command here so we're exing hyphen it
and the container ID will go right after
that then it will spit out the my SQL
command enter in the user which is root
and then ask us for the password so let
me go ahead and copy this really quick
in here and copy the container ID that
it gave us and now replace the
placeholder enter It'll ask us for the
password and as we saw before it was
secret so let me enter that in and now
we are inside of our mySQL database the
next thing it asks us to do is Type in
show databases to confirm that our
databases was created and we see the
to-dos database is here so our commands
ran successfully now we can say exit and
now we have a to-dos database we're
going to skip this part because it's not
really necessary but if you want to
follow it it simply just spins up a DNS
tool that will allow you to see the IP
address of the container and show you
that each container has its own IP
address so this networking step really
is crucial for these two containers to
talk to each other so what I'm going to
do here is I'm actually going to first
remove the container of the getting
started app that we created first
because it's not tied to this network
yet so let me go ahead and remove it
first and then we're going to create
another one using this command here and
as you can see we're doing the same run
command here but with a couple other
flags so there's just you know we're
tying it to the network here there's a
couple other environments like hooking
it up to the mySQL database so that
we're actually able to push data to the
database same thing with the node
version and then initializing the
application with yarn install and and
run Dev so let me go ahead and copy and
paste this over and there we go we
should have another container built with
the note 18 Alpine image instead now if
we want to connect to the mySQL database
let's go ahead and do that here so we're
going to copy this command again copy
and paste this and then we need to get
into the mySQL database so let me copy
and paste
that
enter the password here and it is secret
so now that we're in so we're going to
do the select function here and we're
going to select all from to doore items
and we can see that the three items that
we created inside of the application are
now here inside of the database so we're
confirming that the data that we created
in the volume is now inside of our my
SQL database and that right there is the
power of networking earlier in this
module I also mentioned dock compose and
it makes this whole process that we just
did with this application 10 times
easier again as I mentioned before also
is that Docker compose is a tool that
helps you to find and share multiple
container applications and so we're
going to be doing that right now this
right here was the old command that we
had to run inside of our terminal to get
everything running for the MySQL and to
do app but we can simply do that all of
this in one Docker file and the docker
file now changes to a Docker composed.
yo file or you can shorten it to os.
yaml so we're going to head back into
our terminal here and inside of the
route where we initially put our Docker
file we're going to create a new file
and call it compose do yaml and what
Docker has provided us with were a
couple things so we're going to go ahead
and copy and paste this now make sure it
added to space here but it will air out
if it has an empty space so cover that
space again yaml is very strict with
spacing and indentation so keep that in
mind but the first thing here we're
going to do is specify Services of our
compos file the first one is going to be
our app which is going to contain the
image of the node version 18 so we're
going to run node in this container next
thing we're going to do is add the
command so the command we want to run is
going to be the yarn install and and run
the dev environment there so we're going
to add that here next thing is we're
going to open up the ports and it's
going to be the same port the 127 on
Port 3000 so now we're moving the
working directory to the volume mapping
uh and by doing that we're going to add
the working directory and then the
volumes
so let me go ahead and add that as well
and then finally we're going to add the
environments so these environment
variables are all going to be the my SQL
environment variables so that we can
access the database through the
application itself when we add a need
todos so again the host the user
password database name these are all
there and are going to specified for
this app container now we're going to do
the same but for my SQL so we saw the
app container but now if we back up a
couple spaces is we're going to add the
MySQL container so you can see that
these two are on the same line one being
app with all of its information here and
then MySQL will contain the same but now
we're pulling the MySQL version 8 image
the volumes that we want to use for this
container is going to be the to-do my
SQL data so let me go ahead and add that
and then the overall volumes here are
going to be outside of that and then
finally what we need to do is we're
going to add the environment variables
for the specific container so we can
access it now everything in your
composed. file should look like this
again the top level is identifying what
services that we want this file to
create the first one being our app
container using the node 18 image this
is the command we want to run this is
the port that we want to expose and use
to access this application our working
directory is going to be this root
directory that contains everything here
the volumes we're mapping is going to
use the app this is the environment
variables we use to connect to our MySQL
container that also contains its own
information and so now it's much easier
with Docker compose to run this
application now that we have our
composed. yl file I can open up my
terminal here let me exit my SQL clear
this now all I have to do is run Docker
compose up and I can add The Hyphen D
flag to make sure that this runs in the
background and what that's did just now
was literally spit out two containers
one it looks like it failed because I
have a container running already that
has ,000 so let me go ahead and just
delete this and delete this from the
docker desktop app so we can have a
clean slate and let me run the same
thing and there we go now it's spit out
the getting started app and it contains
our app and my SQL container both of
them running and we have opened on Port
3000 and if I head over into our Local
Host Port 3000 I'm refreshing and you
can see it's all fresh so we are note
we're using a different volume here but
the application is now running
successfully it is attached to our my
SQL database and we can continue and now
add data here that will persist because
we have tied a volume here to both of
these containers now if we wanted to
tear it down all we would have to do is
Docker compose down and that will shut
down and stop our containers from
running and that right there is a simple
rundown of how you can create images in
a container through Docker using Docker
files or a composed. yaml file and then
accessing those containers to do certain
things we ran a application in the form
of a to-do app and we also created a
mySQL database pretty quickly here in
their own environments and that way we
have coworkers that are working on the
same thing they can run the same image
that we're on using the same environment
variables using the same dependencies
and essentially be able to recreate any
problems or just have the same
environment that we're running on every
single time and that is the power of
containerization through Docker we're
going to be using a lot of these skills
in the coming lessons so hopefully that
helps but now let's move move on to the
SQL module where we're going to be using
SQL but we're also going to start our
own little database inside Docker as
well so let's get to it so now that we
have Docker set up and we know the
basics we're going to move it on to SQL
or SQL however else you want to call it
but SQL stands for structured query
language it's a standard language used
for database creation and manipulation
databases like MySQL or postgress use
sqil for you to query any of the data
within their own tables so let's go
ahead and start our playground we're
going to set up a database using
postgress within a Docker container and
then we can create our own tables with
fake data to play around with and we'll
use them later on in the course as well
all right so first things first is I
have a terminal open and I've created a
data engineering database directory
because we're using Docker we do not
have to install postgress locally what
we can do is run the command Docker pull
postgress and what that's going to do is
look up the image of postgress on the
docker Hub pull the latest version of
that down and now we can actually create
a container that's running the postest
image so now we got to start our
postrest container now that we have the
image so I'm going to say Docker run the
name of this container is going to be
data engineering postgress uh the
environment variables that we that I
want are going to be related to
postgress which is going to be
postgress
password and what that's going to be is
just going to be
secret and then I'm going to do the D
flag and we're going to say we're going
to use the postgress image go ahead and
run that now I have my container now
what I want to do is I want to create a
new database inside of postgress so I'm
going to say Docker exec hyphen U for
the user which is just postgress as
default the name of the container which
is just data engineering a
postgress going say create DB
and the name of the database is going to
be
postgress
DB now that we've run that we've created
a sample database inside now let's go
ahead and connect to it so I'm going to
say Docker
exec
slit data
engineering
postgress
psql hyphen U for the user on postgress
and the name of the database which is
going to be postgress
T now we are inside as you can see of
the postgress database if I do
/dt no current tables as of right now so
that's what exactly what we're going to
do we're going to create our first table
I have these commands already written
out so I don't waste as much time so the
first thing I'm going to do just for an
example is create a table called users
so inside this command you see a couple
things so we have an idid of thep type
serial which is also our primary key
here as an identifier we have a first
name which is at most 50 characters we
have a last name which is the same thing
we have an email that is also characters
but we want it to at least be 100 and
then we have a date of birth which is
just in the type of date so we're going
to hit enter it's going to show us that
we have a table so now if I do /dt we
can see that the users table is now
created and populated inside of this
database I'm going to go ahead and copy
in some fake data as well and don't
worry this will all be in the
description below so that way you can
copy and paste this in as you follow
along so I'm going to and copy and paste
this and this is simply just user so it
contains a first name a last name an
email and date of birth so let me go
ahead and enter and you can see it
entered in 14 records so now this brings
us into the First Command we're going to
learn so the First Command we're going
to want to learn is the select command
and it's pretty self-explanatory as you
saw already we entered in 14 rows of
data and and if I wanted to select
anything from that table I'm going to
need to use the select command so I'm
going to say
select and I'm going to add this
asterisk what the asterisk typically
means is a wild card pretty much meaning
you want all of the columns within a
table so you can read this query as
select all now I'm going to add from and
then the last part of this is going to
be the table name so I'm going to say
users and do not forget this is very
important that every query needs to end
in a semicolon otherwise the query won't
go through so make sure you always add a
semicolon at the end of every query so
once I hit enter you're going to see
that I get back a formatted view of the
table that I just queried we saw before
that we entered in 14 rows of data and I
see that I get exactly 14 rows back all
having the ID first name last name email
and date of birth formatted in a much
more pleasing way than what we see up
here the select query is going to be a
frequently used command by everybody who
who uses SQL so make sure you know it
and understand it but again very
straightforward another command that
gets used in conjunction with select is
also going to be distinct we use
distinct in conjunction with select if
we want a specified value within a very
particular column so let's say we want
every single email within the user's
table what we'll say is we're going to
say select
distinct email
from and then we're going to say users
table so again we're reading this back
if you haven't noticed already you
typically all the SQL commands are going
to be in all caps keep in mind you do
not need this but it is much easier and
it is probably best practice to
capitalize every command that is SQL and
lowercase everything that is either a
table or some type of value that you
need but if we're reading this back we
want to select distinct emails from the
users table so again it reads just like
English we add the semicolon if we hit
enter it's going to give us just the
emails in every single distinct email
now keep in mind this is not in order
but we do get 14 rows of data back we
can see that the query was successful so
that's how you can select data from the
whole table to get a better view or
select distinct values within a
particular column but let's move on to
other commands so now that we have our
users table that has data that exists in
there what if we wanted to update some
information say an email if a user
changed their email or a date of birth
if they entered it wrong this is where
the update man comes in handy so let's
say for example if we go back up to our
table that we wanted to change J's email
so what we're going to do is we're going
to say update so the query starts with
update now after update we're going to
enter the table name so we're going to
say users and then we're going to say
set so now we want to address what
column and value we want to change in
the users table so we're going to say
email and then that is going to equal
whatever our value is going to be inside
of single quotes so for example we can
just say you know
newcore mail@gmail.com
the problem with this query is if we
were to hit enter on this it would
change the emails for every single row
inside of the user table which isn't
exactly what we want and if you were
doing this in a production database it
would probably go Haywire so how can we
modify this query for it to actually
only update one person's email inside
the table what we can do is introduce
the wear command so after we set the
email to the new value we're going to
say where and then we're going to say
first uncore
name so now we're saying where the first
name so we're selecting a particular
first name is equals to and the first
name in this case is going to be John
and we're going to hit a semicolon so
again we're going to backtrack here
we're going to update the user table
we're going to set the email so we're
selecting the column email to newor
mail@gmail.com
where our the first name is equals to JN
so that means that we're going to look
for JN inside of the first name column
once we find John we're going to go to
his email and change the email over to
the new value so if I hit enter we can
see that we have one updated change now
if I say select go back to the cap
select all from users table we're going
to see that John's actually changed so
he gets moved down he still has an ID of
one but his email is now new _
mail@gmail.com so again if we're using
the update command it's very helpful if
anything changes in terms of data and we
need to update something that's where
we' use the update command now let's say
you wanted to enter in new data into a
table well that's where the insert
command comes in if you're starting to
see the pattern here SQL commands are
very self-explanatory and the fact that
they read English and kind of like
python so if you wanted to insert new
values you would reach for the insert
command so we're going to create a new
table called the films table add some
films films and then show the insert
command but go more in depth into it all
right so we are back in our database and
I have the command here already I'm
going to create the table of films again
so create table is also a command that
we didn't get really into but again
self-explanatory we're just creating a
table here called films within the
parentheses we're going to see the film
ID with a type we have a title a release
date a price which is new that we're
seeing a decimal type we have a rating
and then a user rating the one thing to
note within the user rating is that
we're checking to see if the number
value that goes into user rating is
greater than or equals to 1 and that the
user rating is less than or equals to 5
so obviously we want to go between 1 and
five here so if I hit enter we're going
to see that if I do /dt which is like LS
in a normal bash terminal is kind of
like listing every table inside of a
database we see that the films table is
now created so let me go ahead and copy
my insert command here and we see that
we have insert into so again self
explanatory we want to insert values
into the films table within the first
set of parentheses we see the names of
the columns that we want to add and
again those are fitting and matching
exactly what we have on this side right
here when we created the table after the
first set of parentheses we have a
values command and after that everything
inside of the parentheses are values
that have to match the order in which
you placed every single column so the
first one we have is a title which is
these are all not fake data but I have
them generated so we have Inception the
release date which is right here in the
date format we have its price in a
decibel format we have the rating of the
movie as well as the user rating of the
movie and so you can see it fits within
this set of parenthesis it fits the
order of this set of parenthesis so if
we hit enter right now you can see that
we've entered in 20 rows of data if I
say select
all from
films we can see that's a little out of
place here because my terminal is a
little big but we can scroll down and we
can see that all the data was entered in
go ahead and skip this line let me make
it smaller so that we can see more of it
but if I hit that again we can see the
table is formatted properly the same way
that the users's table was but that
right there is how you can insert data
into a table it doesn't have to be that
big every single time if we just wanted
to insert one more row it would just be
the exact query back here except just
one more line another really useful
command that you should know is going to
be the limit command imagine you have a
database that has thousands upon
thousands of Records but you only need a
certain amount so you want to limit the
query to that amount that's where limit
comes in so as we saw in the new films
table we saw that we have 20 rows but
what if we only want less than 20 so
let's let's say five that's where we
would use limit so let's do select
all from we're going to go into the
films table but after films typically we
would have that semicolon to end the
query but now we're going to add limit
and then the value of what we want to
limit the query to so because we have 20
we want less than 20 here let's just say
I only want five records to come back if
I hit enter you're going to see that I
only get the first five records in the
table to come back so that is a very
easy to understand command here and very
useful to limit the amount of records
that come back cuz you could imagine as
I said before if you're trying to query
a database or a table that has thousands
of records that query could take a very
long time so if you want that to speed
up a little bit and you only need a
certain amount to see what the data
looks like if it's formatted properly
the limit command is going to be your
best friend the next thing we're going
to cover is going to include some math
here but we're going to go over
aggregate functions in SQL aggregate
functions in SQL allow us to do
computations on top of a single column
through every single row of a table it's
incredibly useful in data analytics
where it allows us to calculate
important metrics and gain insights from
our data so let's get into the first one
the first one is going to be count now
the count function allows us to count
the number of rows depending on if it
matches the condition that we give it so
now that we have our films table let's
say we wanted to count the amount of
films if we don't know how many are
inside the table let's start the query
here so let's say select right after the
select statement we would say count in
the parentheses we would count however
many we want but if I add an asterisk
here that's going to say count every
single record inside of this table if it
matches the condition I'm about to give
it so we're going to say count from
film's table so again this is selecting
the number of Records within this
condition here and what we give it is an
asterisk for all from the films and what
this should give me back is the number
20 because we have 20 rows inside this
column so just remember within this
parenthesis here is going to be the
condition depending on what that
condition is it will spit back to you
always a number depending on if it's
true within that condition and count is
really useful for that the next
aggregate function we're going to look
at is going to be the sum function now
we would use sum to calculate the sum of
all the numbers in a numeric column so
if we take a look here we have a prices
column so now if if we wanted to let's
say calculate the sum of every single
price in this column we would say select
sum inside the parenthesis we would say
price because we want to use the price
column from the film's table so now if
we look back at this we're selecting the
sum function is going to look into the
price column and add up every single
number value within it and it will spit
back to us the total sum of every single
movie that we have inside this table so
if you were to have gone to every single
one of these movies at this price you
would have spent
$228.8 now let's say we want to get the
average of something inside of our table
say for example we want the average user
rating of movies in this table well
that's where the average statement or
the average function comes in it's going
to look the exact same as the sum
function so we're going to say select
but instead of su we're going to say
average or APG and inside the
parenthesis we're going to enter in the
column that we want to take a look at
which is going to be user uncore rating
close the parentheses there and then
we're going to say from the films table
and that then gives us an average of
every single user rating that the movies
have which is going to be 4.6 and lastly
one of the more useful ones is going to
be Max and min max and Min are used to
find the highest and lowest numeric
value within a column so let's look at
our price column again if we wanted to
get the lowest and the highest values in
the prices column our query would look
something like select and then we would
say Max inside the max column our
condition would be the column we want so
we want price we're going to add a comma
here and we're going to say Min again
parentheses and looking at the prices
column from the films table now if I hit
enter here we're going to see the max
value here was $14.99 and the minimum
was $7.99 so the the cheapest movie out
here that was in the table was $7.99
and the max was $4.99 so very helpful to
sift through a big table if you're just
trying to find the highest value and the
lowest value another useful statement in
SQL is going to be group bu we use group
bu to get identical data into groups
it's also typically used with aggregate
functions like the ones we just did like
count sum min max average so that we can
group the result sets into one or more
columns let's take a look at how this
would look if we were to use group bu
with the average aggregate fun function
let's take a look at the films table
again and let's say we want to group the
average user rating based off of the
movies actual rating how would we do
that we're going to select the rating
column here and then we're going to add
a comma and add our aggregate function
since we're stringing together two
select and inside the condition of the
average function we're going to put in
the user uncore rating
column from the films Table after after
that we're going to say Group
by and what we wanted to group that by
is by the rating so we're going to get
the average of every user rating inside
of the film's table and then group the
results by each individual rating so we
have PG-13 we have R and we have G npg
so we should see four rows inside of the
results after I had enter you can see
the average rating for R-rated movies
was
4.61 the average rating for PG-13 is 4.5
PG was 4.8 and G was 4.4 so now you can
see how this could be useful to group
together identical forms of data and
compare them against each other this is
especially important in data analysis
again it allows us to organize the data
into a different way and then run
computation on top of that especially
with them being in groups it's also
important to note the order that we did
this query if we were to have switched
the rating and the average functions
here we would have got a different
result so the order of the query does
matter depending on how you want to
format your data so keep that in mind
one cool feature you can do in SQL is
join two different tables that have
different data sets and get a result
that combines both of the data you need
into a formatted table there are two
different commands that we can use for
this and we're going to go over those
right now the first one being injoin and
the left one being left join they do
very similar things but there are key
differences that that make them unique
so let's go over what those are right
now but before we do that we're going to
need to create another table that we can
use data against alongside our existing
films table so let's first create the
film category table so I'm going to go
ahead and copy and paste this so we have
a category ID a film ID and the category
name these categories match every single
movie that we currently have inside of
the films table now I'm going to go
ahead and insert our values here so let
me go ahead and do that that hit enter
we have 39 records here so now if I do
select all from the Filmore category
table now we can see that we have our
category IDs and we have our film IDs as
well as their category names go ahead
and Skip all these lines here so now we
have two tables that we can use to join
with each other if we want a table where
we have all the movies as well as the
film category ories we're going to learn
about two things right now we're going
to learn about how injin works and we're
going to learn about how aliases work in
your SQL queries so let's go ahead and
get to that so in order to understand
how joins work we need to First create
some tables that go against the data
that we have currently in all those
tables and insert some new ones so that
we can join them together so the first
table we're going to create is going to
be the actor's table so this is going to
have an actor ID and the actor name I'm
going to have all the actors from every
single film that we have currently and
then we're also going to create the film
actors table and this will make sense in
a second so this one is going to have
the film ID an actor ID as well as a
primary key and now into the actors
table are going to go every single name
of each actor that are associated with
the specific films let me go ahead and
insert those and now we also have the
film actors which are going to to
include their IDs as well as the film
IDs so now you can see that we have two
separate tables that we just created if
I do select all from the actors table we
can see that we have actor ID as well as
the actor name all in this table and
then if we say select all from Filmore
actors table you can see that we have a
film ID and an actor ID so this goes
with multiple different tables that we
have relationship with and now we can
focus on how to join all this data
together and make sense of inner join
and left join okay so like I said we're
going to focus on the inner join and
we're also going to add some aliases and
what those are going to look like let me
copy and paste this in here so we can go
over what this looks like first we have
our select statement and now we're going
to go into what we're selecting so we
have f. film ID and this will make sense
in a second we have f. tile we have a.
actor name so we're selecting the film
ID we're selecting the title name as
well as the actor name that's what the
results are going to look like now we're
going to select from the films table and
after the films table is a space and an
F so the Alias that we want to give our
films table is f so now that anytime we
want to access the films table all we
have to do is type f as we can see here
after we select the films table and add
the Alias we're going to do an add our
inner join statement this is where we're
going to add different tables and join
them together so after you say in join
we're going to take on the film actors
table and we're going to give it an
alias of fa so short for film actors and
we're going to join these two tables on
which is why we have on so we're going
to select the film's table and then the
film ID from the film's table if it
equals the same film ID from the film
actor's table that's where we're going
to join those rows and columns on we're
going to add another inner join we can
string on as many joins as we want so in
this case we're going to do two because
we're bringing on the actor's table so
we're going to join the actor's table
and we're going to give it an alas of a
on the fact that any actor IDs from the
film actor table is also equals to the
actor IDs from the actor's table and
lastly we see order by that's a
statement we haven't gone over yet but
we're going to order them by the film
IDs from the film table so we're going
to order them by those film IDs but
we're going to go from the film table so
I know that's a lot to take in but let's
go over it one more time the final table
that we are going to see we're going to
have three different columns we're going
to see the film ID from the film's table
we're going to see the title from the
film's table and then the actor name
from the actor's table and now the
reason we're not seeing the film actor's
table in the select column is because
one we're using the film actor's table
as a bridge to connect the actor names
to their correct films that's what we
did here on this join is we took our
film actors and if we look up at the
film actors table we can see that we
only have a film ID and an actor ID each
of them are just numbers but they
correspond to an actor as well as a
movie so we took the data that we have
from the film actor table and we joined
it on top of the film table now if there
was a film ID that matches any of the
movies inside of the movies or I'm sorry
inside of the films table then we're
going to match those together take that
data and use it for the results section
here now that bridge allows us to say
okay well now we want to join the
actor's table on top of the film actor's
table now now we can associate actors
with the correct movies now that we have
the film IDs and the actors that go with
them so we're taking on the actor's
table in the form of or in the Alias of
a on top of film actors and now if we
have any actor IDs that match the film
IDs in the film ID or in the film actors
table we're going to take that data and
then use that here and then we'll
obviously again order them by the film
ID in the films table a lot to take in
again but if I hit enter we're going to
see that we have a very nice formatted
table here like I said we're ordering by
the f. film ID which we use up here as
well so everything is ordered
chronologically or you know in numerical
order 1 2 3 4 and then that film ID will
match Inception and then Le Naruto
DiCaprio checks out was in Inception Tim
Robbins was in Shashank Redemption
Marlon Brando was in Godfather so you
can see on and on that this does make
sense and now if we were to go and do
select all from the films
table we can see that Inception had a
film ID of one so that checks out right
there um and then if we go to
select all from the actor's
table we can see that Leonardo DiCaprio
had an actor IDF one so all of that data
that we just took in actor idea of one
and film idea of one matches exactly
what it was between all the three
different tables that we had a
relationship with all to give us one
very nice table that we can now use for
any form of data analysis or what any
sort of computation that any of your
teams need and that's really a awesome
way to join multiple different tables
this was an example of inner join left
joins do something similar but there is
a catch between the two that make them
unique as I mentioned before so let's
take a look at what left joins look like
so in order for joins to make sense we
need to add another entry into the films
table so let's go ahead and do that I
have here a single entry that I will
copy and paste right now so I am simply
going back into the fils table and
entering the mystical Adventures movie
so let me go ahead and hit enter and
then if we do select all from films we
can see that the mythical Advent or
mystical Adventures is now added at the
very bottom so now we have 21 so now let
me copy the left join query that we want
to do here and now it's going to look
very similar to the inner join where
we're taking the film ID from the films
table the title from the film's table
and the actor name from the actor's
table again we're adding the aliases
here here with the letter f for the
film's table we're left joining the film
actors table again using that as the
bridge uh it's essentially going to be
the same query but if we were to hit
enter on this right now you can see that
we still do have the table filled out
properly and formatted properly but we
have mystical Adventures but with no
actor so the thing with left joins is
even if there is a null value or it's
missing a value the result table will
still show even if there isn't an exact
match now if we were to go back up to
the query where we do the inner
join after we've now added the new movie
we can see that it doesn't show up so in
jooin if there is a null value and the
condition doesn't the condition isn't
fully met we will not see that in the
result table so for the result table you
see that we only have 20 entries as
opposed to the left join where we have
the 21 but we just have a missing actor
so to now show that this is actually
true we're going to insert a new actor
as well as the new actor IDs to populate
the movie so the movie we added was a
fictional movie so let's go ahead and
add the actor's name so we're going to
add Jane do and John Smith and we're
also going to add the film actors as
well so 21 and 22 so if we were to run
our left join command again we're going
to see that mystical Adventures actually
does populate now but we're going to see
that the mystical Adventures actually
does populate now with the actor name so
this kind of just proves that no matter
what left joins will always show the
result table even if the conditions
aren't meant and there is a null value
there's two more commands we're going to
go over the first one is going to be
Union and the second one is going to be
Union all these do get a little mixed up
with the inner joint and left joint
since they kind of function the same way
in terms of how they work but they are
completely different and let's go over
what makes them unique here so the next
two commands are going to be Union and
Union all these are going to be the last
commands that we go over so we actually
use the union operator to string
together two select statements but with
the Union statement it actually removes
any duplicate rows with the same values
but with Union all you're going to get
duplicate rows in the result set table
so it kind of functions the same way as
in joint and left joint in terms of
their differences but the queries are
going to be very different so let's go
ahead and take a look at what that looks
like all right so back in the terminal
we're going to copy this Union command
and we're going to go over every single
line so with this command we're going to
select title as name from film so we're
going to use the name Alias we never use
the as operator it is completely
optional when giving aliases to use as
so you can omit this when doing it but
it makes it a little bit more clear if
we say Select Title as name so instead
of the column being named title it's
going to be called name when we get the
result table from the films table and
then we're going to add the union
operator here and then string on another
select statement so we're going to
select the actor name as name from the
actor's table and we're going to order
them by name so if I hit enter here
you're going to see that doesn't really
make too much sense but we can see how
it works kind of we have one column
since we named them both name down here
and we're putting down this is an actor
this is an actor this is the name of the
movie so we put together a bunch of
names and we order them alphabetically
by name now if if we were to do that
again but instead we were to change the
actor name to actor and hit enter and it
would be the same thing for Union all
except remember there are going to be
duplicate rows or duplicate values
within here so if we were to scroll down
you can see that we get Tom Hanks twice
whereas in the table above we only got
Tom Hanks once so again this is a prime
example of Union and Union all so we're
putting together all the data that we're
grabbing using two select statements
into one result table another cool
little thing you can do in SQL that's
actually going to be very useful later
down the line especially as a data
engineer is going to be something called
subqueries we've seen them a little bit
here by using the parentheses but let me
go ahead and show you what one looks
like and then we'll go over it so let me
copy and paste it over so as you can see
here we have first a select statement
where we're selecting the title now
inside of that we have a par we have a
comma and then inside a set of
parentheses we're using another select
statement but we're selecting the actor
name and again using aliases and a join
so from actors Alias of a we're joining
the film actors again using it as a
bridge and then the final result from
this select statement is going to be the
actor name and then we're pulling this
from films using the Alias F so this is
just a string select statement but a
subquery so before this finishes we're
going to to run and find the title from
the films table but then we're also
going to look here SQL will go ahead and
execute this query and then add it into
the results table so right now what this
is doing is it's retrieving the films
title along with the name of one of its
actors so if we go ahead andit enter you
can see that it's kind of the same thing
what we did earlier in the course where
we joined two different tables but we
used a subquery instead subqueries can
be used in multiple different ways we
saw this being used used in the select
Clause here but we can actually use this
also with the in operator so if we
wanted to retrieve films that have
either you know let's say Leonardo
DiCaprio or Tom Hanks this is what the
query would actually look like so let me
go ahead and show you so we're selecting
the title from the films table where the
film ID in and then this is where our
subquery would start this is where we're
going to say hey we're looking for any
films and we want the name of them if
the condition is met here where the
actor's name name is either Leonardo
DiCaprio or Tom Hanks so we're looking
for both of these movies so we're going
to say Obviously go into the film
actor's table and do another join here
so we're adding that condition by
joining in other tables and that's where
subquery can really become useful here
so if I enter you're going to see that
we're only going to get the titles back
and Inception Force gum and Toy Story
are going to be the three movies that
contain leard DiCaprio or Tom Hanks and
obviously most of us have seen that so
that checks out but that is a quick
little intro Pro and awesome little
thing we can do in SQL
subqueries all right so now that we've
gone through SQL we can finally get into
building our first data pipeline this is
going to evolve as the course progresses
but we're going to start off by building
this data pipelines from scratch using a
python script and moving data that way
we're also going to be using Docker to
host both of our source and destination
databases using postgress so you'll get
to see how this all coincides and works
together with Docker one thing to note
before we keep moving on is there is a
repo for this whole project you can see
it here with a read me on how to get
started and how everything works if you
go up here to the branches you can see
the evolution of this project so first
we're going to be starting with just the
main elt script and then we're going to
be adding on a Cron job to show
orchestration from there we're going to
be adding DBT to the mix which we'll get
into later and then also airflow and
then eventually air bite so there's
going to be this progression of the
course to show kind of how a main elt
script uh that's created manually would
look and then as we add in more open
source tooling you'll kind of see the
power of how everything works together
and why you know we are using these open
source tools in the first place so just
for your reference make sure to look in
the description and you can find this
link here to my GitHub repo with
everything you need to see just in case
you get stuck on something but for the
rest of the project I'm going to be
creating a new directory but it will
directly reference this project so just
keep an eye on this when you're working
through it all right so I have my
terminal open so let's go ahead and
create our first directory here I'm
going to say make and then for here I'm
going to say elt and then we're going to
CD into elt um and then from there we're
going to say touch
_
script.py let's also create a Docker
file so I'm going to use Docker compos
in this so I'm going to say Docker
compos
and let's go ahead and open that up okay
so now you can see we have two files
that we just created we have the elt
script and then we also have the docker
compos file all empty but we're going to
fill this out now the first thing we're
going to do is actually fill out this
Docker compose file in order to have the
two databases that we need one being our
source where our data is coming from and
the destination where we want to send
data to so that way we can use the elt
script to move data between those two
now we're going to use postgress for
this example because we canuse use it as
an open source database and so let's go
ahead and fill this out so the first
thing we need is going to be the version
and uh version three is going to be what
I'm going to be using for the doc compos
file now we list our services so in here
this is where we name our first service
and in this case I'm going to name it
Source postgress that's going to be our
first service now remember with Amo
files it is very crucial for you to have
proper spacing within the file itself if
not the yo file is not going to read
properly and it'll actually error out if
you don't follow the correct tabbing and
indentation so keep that in mind um so
the first thing we're going to do is
list the image and for the image here
I'm just going to say we want to pull
from dockerhub the postgress image and
the latest version of it so that way
we're always up to date the ports so
this is going to be very important for
us in terms of accessing the actual
service itself so with the source and
the destination databases we need to
expose the ports so that we can actually
access them on the local host and so for
this I'm going to say we're going to
open this up on 5433 and by default we
need to do 5432 I believe so let's go
ahead and do that now for the networks
we're going to create a network for all
of our containers so you can look at all
these Services as a single container in
each single container contains an image
that the runtime is going to use and so
we actually need to create a network for
all of these different containers to
talk to now I'm going to name it _
Network and we will see that at the end
of this file we're going to have a well
I can actually just do this right now so
we're going to have a networks section
and in there we'll list the _ network we
also have to specify this is going to be
a bridge driver um you don't have to
worry about that what that means but
just know that within the network all of
the containers are going to recognize
that this is the network we want it to
talk uh remember that is outside of the
services tab this is going to be its own
section here with its own properties so
make sure that you're doing that there
now within the source postest service
we're going to do some environment
variables here that are going to be very
important for the first one we're going
to do the
postgress database so this is going to
the name our database and for the name
we're going to say sourcecore DB keep it
very simple uh the next one we're going
to do is going to be the user so postore
user and this one let me uh actually
should be this way not an equal sign it
should be a colon my bad this is going
to be user postgress as default and then
obviously the next one is going to be
password this you can change to however
you want it to be I'm going to say
secret for this one and now for the
volumes this is going to make way more
sense and I I should actually create
this um this folder now but we're going
to create an elt folder we're actually
going to drag this elt script into their
folder just so we can have some
separation between everything the docker
composed file will remain in the root
but um for the next one we're going to
say volumes and if we remember what we
were talking about in the docker section
the volumes is is how we're able to
persist data so each container can
create a volume and then whatever we're
doing inside of that Docker container
will contain the data that we're
utilizing within that volume so that
data will always persist as long as we
do not delete it from within Docker what
I'm going to do here is I'm going to
specify the path of so Source this will
make a lot more sense in a second so
Source IND justy uh init so we're
actually going to have some data that
we're going to initialize this postgress
database with and and the init SQL
folder or file sorry that we're going to
create inside of the source DB init
folder is what we're going to utilize
and so after we've done that we're going
to map this uh so if you see the colon
after this this uh directory we're
actually mapping this to the directory
within the docker container so you could
see this as this is our local directory
and we're going to map this over into
the docker directory and where this is
going to go is going to go into the
docker entry point init db. d/ init SQL
okay so this should be exactly what it
looks like for you and this is going to
be the same it pretty much looks
identical so we're actually going to do
this and I'm going to do shift option
down to duplicate this we're going to
add a space here so this is going to be
our very first service here which is
going to be the source database and now
what we want to create here is going to
be the destination database uh and we're
going to change the port here to 5434 we
were going to keep this on the network
on the elt network now this also needs
to change so this is going to be
destination ZB we'll keep user and
password the same and we actually don't
want any volume section here why because
we don't want to save the data every
single time for testing purposes I want
to make sure that the El script runs
every single time successfully and so if
the data persists I can't confirm or
deny that the elt script is actually
working so that every single time we
kill this Docker container I want the
data to vanish so that's what we're
doing here for the next service and the
last one we're going to do for this
section is going to be the elt script
now why do we need to create one here
well we need to create one in order for
Docker to see that we're actually
utilizing a script here to send data
from these source and destination
databases so we actually have to use
Docker for this and use it for the
runtime to actually run the script
itself instead of us having to manually
do it so what we're going to do here is
utilize the manual docker files at the
same time as using Docker composed
there's different reasons for for doing
this I think it's just easier to run
certain commands utilizing it this way
and we'll actually see what what this is
doing so it's going to look a little
different so we're going to say build
under the build property we're going to
add some context uh and the context is
essentially what file we're we're
building off of and so we're going to
say ltor script inside of the root
folder so it's going to be here and it's
going to be root in reference to where
the docker file is and we're just going
to say Docker file but I'm going to
capitalize the D here um cuz that's what
I'm going to do when we create it now
the command we're going to run I think
that's changed it the command we're
going to run we're going to put this in
early brackets we're going to say python
since this is a python file and then
eltor
script. same thing with the networks so
we're going to say networks and then
elore Network there now this is going to
be one thing that we learned in Docker
so the depends on property here is that
this container depends on other
containers and so if it has any
dependencies this container won't
initialize until the other containers it
depends on are finished building and so
if I say this depends on both the source
as well as the
destination services this script will
not run until these two are finished
initializing in which it does take time
which would make sense right because we
need to initialize the destination
database because there is no way for us
to move data if there is no data in here
yet and this isn't even ready we don't
want the script to run or else we're
going to run into a lot of errors here
so this is exactly why I wanted to use a
Docker container for the elt script so
that way we can control the way that it
functions so now that we have this going
on we're going to create a new file here
we're going to say Docker file just like
we said and now within the docker file
this is where we're going to specify a
couple things so obviously the structure
is going to look a little different here
but from is going to be the actual image
we want to use so we're going to say 3.8
H slim is going to be the first one that
we're going to use here now what we want
to do is we want to install postest with
some command line tools so we're going
to say run um and apt get since it's
running off of Linux apt get update and
and appt get install y
postgress UL so that's going to install
the postgress client there we're also
going to copy so we're going to copy the
contents of the actual elt script so
that the docker container has access to
it and so we're going to say elt or
script.py this so make sure you have
that period at the end and then the
command we're going to run is again
python
eltor so that is going to be the
structure here now the next thing we're
going to do is actually create our
source destination and initialize it
with some data so let's go ahead and do
that so if you go over to the repo of
the custom elt project you're going to
see this folder called Source DB
underscore and knit now what this is
primarily holding is a SQL file that
contains all fake data so we're going to
create a couple tables and then insert
values into them so that's exactly what
we're going to go do so let me go back
and switch I'm going to create a new
folder and we're going to name it Source
dbor init as we just saw inside of there
I'm going to do init SQL and if you
remember it's exactly what we did here
so we're pointing that exact file over
into this directory of the container so
that we have access to it we're creating
a mapping of this over into the docker
container so that way we can actually
run the commands to initialize the
source database from there now inside of
this what we're going to do is just go
in here and copy I believe I can just
copy everything here and paste it so
that's exactly what you're going to do
just make sure you have access to this
copy everything that you see inside the
folder so we can save some time going to
create a couple tables and insert some
fake data for us like I mentioned we're
going to save that and now we can
actually go up about running this and
and creating everything so the way to do
that is going to be inside of our elt
script so let's fill out elt script now
all right so we are in our elt script
here and there's a couple things that
we're going to import so we're going to
import the subprocess first so this is
how we're allowing to control inputs and
outputs and things like that we're also
going to import time um this is going to
be make sense a little bit later but the
first thing we want to do is obviously
double check and I know that the docker
composed file checks to make sure that
the elt script will not run unless the
source and the destination database are
working but we can also run a fallback
just in case so we're going to create
this function here called weight 4ore
postgress and uh some of the variables
we need are going to be the host we're
going to need the maxor retries the
default value here is going to be five
delay in seconds we're going to leave at
five so after that what goes inside this
function uh we're going to say
retries is zero while retri is less than
Max retries we are going to say try
results equals subprocess run and then
in here we're going to say PG uncore is
ready this say hyphen H going to post
here check equals true now this is all
going to be correlated to postest
directly capture output true and then
the text is true a couple checks here
right uh I think I forgot something here
move this over and then we're also going
to put an if condition here if accepting
connections so obviously we're pinging
the actual database itself to make sure
that it's ready to go or if it is
accepting connections we're going to say
print successfully uh connected to
postgress and then we're also going to
return true here and accept subprocess
do called process error as e
we're going to say print and F error
connecting to post stress colon here I'm
going to use that F here or sorry e for
the error oh this to be inside
retries if it errors we're going to add
one to the retry plus equals 1 also
going and add another print statement
here and we're going to say f retrying
in play seconds
attempt fiz this is all just for log in
here and then Mac
tries here see where this isue here
outside of the print we're going to say
time do sleep delay seconds and then
outside of the accept print Max R tries
reached exiting in case all else fails
and then we're going to return false
Okay cool so that is going to be our
check function here so I know that was a
lot but you tries spelled that wrong
both times
all good okay that should fix it cool
now we don't have any weird Squigly now
we're going to get into actually
building out the initialization of the
source database and then moving on to
the destination well we can also add
this so we're going to say if not wait
uh underscore 4ore postgress post equals
sourcecore postgress then we're going to
say exit with the eror with code one
print um starting LT script well now we
can actually do this so we're going to
say sourcecore config open this object
here and so the first thing we need to
specify is going to be the DB name and
we're going to be using dump files here
if you're familiar with postgress we can
use dump files to initialize the actual
database but also use those and dump
files into the destination so that's
exactly how we're going to be using this
batch script here for our elt and so
we're going to say uh Source DB is going
to be the name of our DB name it's
actually not a uh sign it's going to be
that and then then let me add our comma
here same thing here so we're going to
say user is going to be what we
specified so these are all information
that we had in the docker composed file
this is going to be the password um and
then the password was secret now for
this next one we're going to say host
now the host should be the name of the
service uh that we put inside of the
docker compost file so we're going to
say sourcecore post that is going to be
the source config now we're going to do
the exact same thing for the destination
unor config DB name is
destination DB username is if I can type
properly post address password is going
to secret as well and then the host is
going to
destination this destination yep no
typos there perfect now we need to
create the dump command for initializing
The Source data so underneath here we're
going to say dump underscore command
we're going to say PG dump which is the
command here that we're going to use um
the H flag hyph H we'll use the
sourcecore config and we're going to
point to the host since that's our host
um let me make sure that this has a
comma for the user so we're going to say
hyphen U we're going to say Source
config and we're going to point it to
user so you can see kind of what we're
mapping each individual flag so the host
user password all that stuff too so
we're going to also do uh hyphen d for
the database name and we're going to
point it to sourcecore config D name
hyphen f is going to be the file that
we're going to use and where we're
pointing that is going to be dataor dump
needs to be single quotes
dataor dump. SE if we add this flag
hyphen W it will not prompt us for the
password which we don't have to do every
single time which is nice so the other
thing too is we're going to set the
environment variable to avoid the
password dump so we're going to say
subprocessor EnV equals di uh PG
password equals Source config password
so now we we've created a password RPG
password environment variable that will
not ask us for the password every single
time now we're going to execute this
dump command so we're going to say
subprocess do run dump command which is
the one we just created point it to the
environment variable that we just
created so subprocessor EnV and then
check equals true so that's going to
dump everything into the source datab
this now we actually need to get
everything from the source database over
to the destination so we're going to
create a load command and it's going to
look pretty much identical to this so
what I'm going to do is copy and paste
everything here but we're going to make
some slight modifications so instead of
PG dump we're going to say psql so we're
actually going to get into this SQL
command line tool we're going to point
it to the host but instead of source it
needs to be destination the user is also
the same so we need to point it to the
destination database name is going to be
the
[Music]
same now we need to or well we don't
need this since we're not pointing it to
a file well we do what we're actually
going to do is concatenate this so we're
going to put two commands here we're
going to do hyphen a comma F we're going
to delete the W uh and then we're still
pointing it to the data. dump. SQL file
now now we're going to do the same
environment variable with
subprocessor EnV equals uh we're
actually copy and paste this over again
cuz I mean it's literally the exact same
thing except we're going to be using the
destination
here destination config now we need to
execute the load command um so what
we're going to do is we're going to say
subprocess do run load command EnV is
going to equal sub processore EnV and
then we're going to do the check equals
true again and we're going to print just
for our own purposes ending elt script
cool so now this is going to be our full
on elt script now how do we run this
well what we're going to do is use
Docker to completely run everything here
so let's go ahead and take a look at
what that looks like because we've made
everything and hooked everything up with
do ER compose it's going to be as simple
as this all we have to do inside of our
terminal obviously make sure that we're
in the directory that we created I'm
going to run Docker compose up uh I
forgot to do this so I forgot to change
the host to hostress here um let me make
sure that's that okay so I had a slight
error but all we have to do is we're
going to do Docker compose up what say
Docker compose services. Source oh does
it not need this uh I might have screwed
up here again which is fine we all make
mistakes so it doesn't actually need
this section here uh let's see if that
will fix it we're going to leave this in
here all right we're running into a
couple things here so _ script so let's
do let's just debug this live cuz why
not/ scripts so this should just be elt
I'm pretty sure there you go okay so
just a couple errors here but hey
nothing that's going to shake us up but
so now that we run Docker compose up
we're actually going to go through and
build out the images so we're pulling
down from the docker post or from Docker
Hub to uh build out these images so now
what we can see is we might be running
into something here but as you can see
in the logs and let me pull this over so
you can actually see it so through the
logs what we've done is we have we've
initialized the destination database and
the source database which is good and
then we've also created the database
we've inserted a couple tables and then
the values for them but it looks like we
ran into an issue with the elt scripts
uh starting elt script so it looks like
that was good trace back on line
[Music]
uh okay so let's look at our PG script
so you can kind of see like all the
little nuances here with creating a bat
script and like this is on purpose uh I
I wanted to make sure that we ran into
some issues here I mean obviously I
would like to not run into issues but
comes with coding comes with building
out these things manually and we'll see
that it gets a little bit easier to deal
with later down the line um so on line
54 is when it said that we had a bug
here so subprocess run dump command I
think this should be a hph U or capital
u here go ahead and try this one more
time so what we're going to do is Docker
compos
down type oh my God okay so the source
is ready to connect still running into
an issue here um on the subprocess still
on line
54 so we've started the elt script
return nonzero exit status let's try
without the check here no that's not it
DB name sourcecore DB post you got
secret Source postgress
destination or postgress okay so I've
deleted the image on Docker let's try
running this one more time let's build
the image again and see if it fixes it e
error oh I see the issue okay so I
screwed that up I think that should be
good now so let's Docker compos down
again Docker compose up just a casual
typo error here I believe it's still not
going to work here cuz I think it's
still readed the old one so what I'm
going to do is kill this Docker compose
up or sorry Docker compose down rid of
these now let's go into Docker and you
can see kind of like what the
troubleshooting so we built this image
and I don't think it's changed it so I'm
going to delete that um we're going to
go back into the terminal here say dock
compos up so we're going to rebuild the
image and it
should there we go okay so now you can
see after some troubleshooting and then
some small typos here and there uh we
have
successfully gotten our logs back and
then at the end we had our ending elt
script so the way to check our work now
is if we open a new terminal let me make
this a little bit bigger go back into
our other directory so CDT I'm going to
say Docker exec and this is from what we
learned in the other tutorial on Docker
so Docker exact and we're going to use
the interactive flag here uh we're going
to grab the name of our _ script 1 so I
believe the full name of it should be
this so we're going to grab I'm sorry
we're not grabbing this we want to grab
the destination name so we're going to
grab _ postgress one so that's going to
be the name then we're going to say psql
we want to run the command line the
postgress command line hyphen U with the
user user postgress now if I hit enter
we're going to be in here the one thing
we do need to do is we're going to say/
C for connect to the
destination DB so now we can see that we
are in the destination database now if I
do slash this is backs slash by the way
or forward forward slash I think uh is/
DT you can see that all of the tables
are now inside of the destination
database now if I do select all from
actors I need to add the semicolon you
can see that all the data that we
inserted into the source database is now
into the destination database this is
now fully working it is not automated at
all but you can see that our bat script
is now successfully working just by
simply taking the dump commands that are
built into postgress and then moving
those in to the destination database now
this is postrest to postrest so this is
very very simple but you can see that
even this is a very basic script but
there's a lot of moving Parts when it
comes to building out a script manually
and so when things change or if you're
trying to connect postgress over into
let's say another database type where
you potentially have to match schema and
things like that in this case we didn't
have to worry about that because the
same database same protocol and
everything but if we're working with
something else it can get very very
tricky so that's why we're going to be
implementing a lot more open source
tooling but for this next part we're
actually going to add a Cron job to this
to automate the script a little bit
because as of right now we are simply
just
manually triggering this so if we needed
to do this every day every 3 days we
could actually add that in here so let's
go ahead and do that now okay so
actually I lied the next evolution is
not going to be the KRON job next it's
actually going to be DBT DBT is going to
be an open source tool that we can
utilize here in order to write custom
Transformations or custom models on top
of the data that we've just sent into
the destination database so you can take
for example that we had a use case where
this destination database is primarily
going to be used by data analysts or
some sort of data scientist and they
need their data formatted or structured
in a certain way where we're combining
certain tables together they can't write
SQL or something like that and they
actually just need it a certain way or
something along those lines we can use
DBT to have those custom models so that
by the time the data is inside the
destination we can run DBT on top of
that data and then write custom models
here creating custom tables and things
like that and it allows us to have
certain capabilities it also allows us
to even write python to run SQL scripts
and things like that so let's go ahead
and see what that looks like and
implement it now there are a couple
prerequisites you need in order to run
DBT successfully on your machine or even
using Docker so let's go ahead and take
a look at what that looks like and
actually get installed all right so I'm
here on the DPT docs which we will also
list down in the description just so you
can get to it pretty easily now there is
some things you need to do locally uh
not everything you can do here Docker so
the first thing you need to do is
obviously I'm on a Mac so most of the
instructions here are going to be for
Mac but you do need to have this
installed locally and the way to do that
is if you probably have Pip if you have
python installed and so you're going to
follow all these instructions uh I think
you could pretty much skip these ones
right here uh you're going to want to
follow this one for sure I think
actually you can probably skip that one
too the main one here is installing the
actual adapter you're not just
installing the adapter but you're also
installing DB T core which is the
opsource version of DBT now I've already
done this but if you run DBT install DBT
hyphen postgress we're installing the
adapter of postgress that utilizes DBT
as well as DBT core you're going to go
ahead and run that locally I've already
done that uh as you could see here so if
I say uh DBT hyen hyen version you can
see that it's going to list pretty much
I have 1.62 installed I'm not going to
update for the sake of this tutorial but
there's 1.66 and I have the post cres
version installed as well so make sure
you go through this installation really
quickly and that way we can actually go
through and create our models so make
sure you do that that is just the only
prerequisite for this section okay so
now that we have DBT installed let me go
ahead and show you how we can initialize
a project here so it's as simple as DBT
innit we're going to run DBT innit
inside of the root directory excuse me
uh now it's going to ask us for the name
of our project we're going to say uh
custom I don't know custom _ postgress
so it's going to say custom _ postgress
and you can see it's creating these
folders here for us now we have the
database we would like to use it's
asking us right here for postgress and
obviously it's the only adapter that we
installed so we're going to hit number
one and therefore it's created us our
it's created two folders actually if we
take a look on the right left hand side
it's created logs for us so we now have
logs for anything regarding DBT as well
as our project for DBT so it has a
couple folders here analys macros models
seats snapshots and tests primarily what
we're going to be focusing on is the
models and macros for now and then the
the rest of it is is kind of like you
know you can learn as you go but for the
sake of this tutorial we're going to
focusing on these folders here so there
are other couple things that we need to
do in order to set up the project itself
before we actually write our models the
one thing we actually have to do is
going to be this so I've just copi and
pasted this one command but you're going
to do Nano and inside of the complete
route of your local machine when you
install all DBT using pip it actually
creates this DBT directory and inside
that folder is a profiles. yl file so
what we're going to do is go in there
and you can see that I've already set
this up but inside of the dev profile it
does say post Crestor Transformations
I'm going to go ahead and change this
because this is now different so what
I've done now is I'm going to do change
the name of this because it's no longer
post Transformations that's what I
normally did uh this is going to be
custom postgress you can see it's done
that down here it it is actually done
that down here actually you know what
I'm probably just going to do that
instead I'm going to post
address so now that we're inside of this
folder you can see that I've already
done this prior but if we were to go
down here into the custom post crust
profile which is created for me because
of this new project you can see here
there there's two different outputs
there's prod and Dev we're going to be
primarily focusing on dev and we do need
to fill out the actual information here
so inside of host I'm actually going to
do host. doer. internal which is needed
in order for DVT to actually recognize
the docker containers that we were
trying to access here which is going to
be our destination database so make sure
that this says host. doer. internal and
it'll read the actual Network or IP
address of your Docker container for the
destination database for the port here
this is going to be 5434 I'm pretty sure
for the destination for the user we're
going to change this over to postest for
the
password we're going to change this over
to
secret DB name will be destination _ DB
and then I forget what I actually put
for the schema here uh schema should be
public and then I forgot to fill out the
threads here so let's change this to one
all right so and the target here is
going to be Dev so obviously make sure
that says it by default it should just
Target the dev profile but now that we
have our information filled out here it
should have the correct information to
connect to our destination database I
believe if I do write out maybe not
write out but if we say x save modified
we're going to hit yes tab to complete
and hit enter okay so this should have
saved it now the other thing to do here
is inside of the DBT pro. file the one
thing to note is that obviously the
profile we just wrote is the custom _
postgress you don't have to change
anything here except for this bottom SE
inside of the bottom section is going to
be how we're forming our models now
inside of the models folder you can see
that there's an example folder and then
a couple of models here what we're
actually going to do is we're going to
change this there's a couple options
inside the material section but because
we're using postest tables we actually
want to change this to table if you keep
it as view we're actually not going to
see any of the tables that we created
come through or anything like that or
DBT is not going to be able to recognize
them so we have to change it to a table
now that we've done that we can actually
go in and write our models so let's go
ahead and do that all right so we are
inside of the models folder here and
inside of this example folder are some
custom examples that they have created
for us uh we don't really need to see
this because we're going to be writing
our own so I'm actually going to go
ahead and delete both of these we're
going to keep the schema. yaml for now
well we're going to reference that later
but let's create our models here so you
can think of models as just SQL files
we're just querying the data but we're
morphing the data around to the needs
that we need so we just do it once here
and then once the destination database
has its data everything that we've
queried here all the modifications and
the new tables that we've created will
end up inside of the destination
database and you'll see what I mean by
all that once we have it all hooked up
the first thing we need to do is
actually Source the data itself because
it can't just simply reference tables
inside of a destination database without
having the actual reference itself so
what we're going to do is we're going to
create our first one so we're going to
say Filmore actors which is a table that
we're actually writing over into the
destination database and this is simply
just creating a reference for us to
create the custom models so this isn't
necessarily a custom model here um so
we're going to write some some SQL here
select all from and then we're going to
do double curly brackets here and inside
of that we're going to say the source of
our data is going to come from
destination database and the name it for
this that we're going to reference it
from is going to be Filmore actors we're
going to need to wrap both of these in
single quotes very cool now what we've
done is we've sourced the destination
database and we've taken the film
actor's table and now we have a film
actors reference let me go ahead and
copy and paste this we're going to do
that again for the actors table so
actors. SQL we're going to paste this in
here and we're simply going to change
this over to actors and we're going to
do the same for films films. SQL so we
have our references now we can actually
create our custom models but again
before we do that we have to have some
prerequisite work so for the schemas
these are our custom models here our DBT
models and we do have to specify what
the schema of these are going to be so
that if we do need to test anything
which you should be testing you can run
a model or you can run DBT against all
of these SQL files and if it doesn't
match what we've specified inside the
schema we're going to get thrown back
errrors so you should definitely always
do this what I'm going to do is I'm
going to head over into our file here
and I'm going to look into to the models
and example folder and we're going to
have a couple things so schema. AML is
what we want we see that there's a films
table here and every bit of schema here
for that one the actors film actors film
ratings I think I need the film ratings
one two as a yeah that's fine so what
we're going to actually just do here is
copy and paste this whole thing I
implore you to do that too we're going
to paste that in there and now we have
the schema for all the tables that we
just added now the other thing too that
we need to do is we're going to go ahead
and copy over the sources. EML so now
we're specifying the raw data from the
destination database so I'm going to
copy this as well and you can see film
actor and film actors literally the
exact tables that we just copied so
we're going to go in here and create a
new file called sources. EML and paste
everything that we just saw so now we
actually have sources that we can point
to regarding these files or tables
essentially that we're querying from so
you can see if we think about the this
from the top down data is theoretically
already written inside of the
destination database DBT is going to run
after we've move data over so the data
is already there and from there what
we're doing is taking in the data so
that way we can modify it and create a
custom model with that data so all we're
doing here is referencing data that we
already have now let's go in and create
the custom models to formulate and
modify the data we have into a table
that we want okay so the first model
we're going to create inside of the
example folder I'm going to name Filmore
ratings. sequel so what we're going to
be doing is appending the films as well
as the actors together to create one
table but it's going to be primarily
focused on the film ratings so let's get
to it all right so what we're going to
do inside of this file is we're actually
going to create two different tables and
then use a join to create one if that
makes sense so the first one we're going
to call is with filmscore with ratings
as and then this is where we're going to
run our squl to create this table so
we're going to say select
Filmore ID
title release underscore date make sure
you're adding commas price rating these
are all from the table that we already
have this is going to be user rating
this is where we add something very
specific so this is going to be a case
so what the case is kind of like you can
think of an if statement per se so we're
going to say when user rating is greater
than or equals to uh let's say
4.5 then we want the rating to say
excellent uh we're going to add another
one where user rating is going to be
greater than or equals to 4.0 so kind of
like in the in between there and we're
going to say that we want the rating to
read good and then the last one we're
going to do is going to the user rating
is going to be greater than or equ = to
3.0 then we're going to say that this is
going to be average else we're going to
label it as poor and we're going to end
as rating uncore
category so that ends this case
statement here and this is where the
reference comes in so we're going to say
from and we're going to open the double
curly brackets again and if we say ref
parentheses films we're going to be
pulling from this here because we
labeled it as films so now we can
actually reference it here within this
little query here one thing I forgot to
mention for this specifically is you saw
that we say with and as or with films
with ratings this is actually what's
referred to as a CTE or Comon table
expression so you can see this as a
wrapper of this query kind of like a
subquery per se but it makes it easy to
write queries that are maintainable and
they're also scoped just to this CTE so
it will not like go outside of this so
this allows us to write subqueries and
then ultimately reference them later
inside of this file so it is actually
really really nice part of DBT that lets
us write CTE uh to kind of formulate
these custom models so that's just
something I forgot to mention when we
were first writing this but remember
this is a CTE or Common Table expression
all right so now that we have our first
CTE so let's write the second one I
added a comma after the CTE so that way
we can string on another one this one is
going to be films with underscore with
actors as and then that's going to open
our CTE here our second one so we're
going to say select and we're going to
do the Alias here um f.
Filmore ID f. tile and then we're going
to do a string aggregator or string
aggregation with a.
actor undor name we're going to pend it
with a comma there and we're going to do
as actors so we're aggregating actor
names for each film here and then we're
also going to hit the reference so from
double curly brackets reference films
and then obviously we're going to enable
the Alias here with f my auto completes
that but there we go so then we're also
going to left join Filmore actors table
and we're going to give that fa for film
actors on f. Filmore ID if it equals the
film actors. film ID uh we're going to
do another left join here referencing
the this left join we needed this so
let's go ahead and do that so forgot the
curly brackets or I'm sorry the uh
parenthesis and single quotes there um
let's add the actors for this reference
obviously this one is going to be a on
fa. actor _ ID if it equals the a. actor
ID and then we're going to group by the
f. Filmore ID and the f. tile okay so
that's going to be the second CT so we
have two now technically two queries
films with ratings and the films with
actors so we've taken the film ID and
the title and we've joined the two
tables that we had here we had the film
actors and the actors table so these are
obviously you know we worked with these
before but the film actors and the
actors is the bridge to the film's table
so now we can actually join them to
create one so now we're going to have
the main query here we're going to
select fwf do asterisk here and we're
going to say fwa film with actors.
actors from the filmscore with now you
can see uncore ratings you can see how
we're referencing the actual CTE now and
we're going to label this as fwf for the
Alias then we're going to say left join
films with actors which we're going to
label fwa on
fwf do Filmore ID if it equals the film
with actors do
Filmore now we're creating essentially
what could be two tables two tables
using the references we've created and
now we're actually joining them together
using this custom model now if we were
to want to run this we now need to set
up the dock container for DBT so let's
go ahead and do that and then run this
custom model just to see what it would
look like okay so we are back inside of
our Docker compost file let's go ahead
and add the DBT service so underneath
the elt script I'm going to say DBT
which is going to be the name of our
service the image I want to use is going
to be GHC r.i / DBT Labs DBT postgress
and then the version is
1.47 uh this as of right now at the time
of this recording is most likely out of
date but it's just what I use so I'm
going to go ahead and run with it the
command I'm going to run here uh I'm
actually going to run a couple now I'm
going to open this square brackets and
the first one I'm going to do is run so
this is technically DB DT run DBT run is
the command you would use in order to
run your models on top of the
destination so I'm going to string a
couple here so we're going to say run
and then we're actually going to do
we're going to point to the profiles
directory so if I do double hyphen
profiles hypher uh not period I need a
comma we're going to say that is going
to be in the uh root here and then if
we're going to point to the project
directory then we're going
2.2 SL DBT which is the name essentially
going to be the name of our project
directory here the one thing I also want
to do uh well we can leave this out for
now actually um so after that we're
going to do networks and this will be
altore Network so we can keep it on the
same network here and now we're going to
point some volumes here so at the
volumes we have the actual project
itself so you notice I said / DBT so
here we're actually going to create
another mapping to point Point 2/ DBT
because if we remember correctly on
Docker containers every directory here
is pretty much going to be pointing to
the directory inside of the actual
Docker container and not your local
machine so you have to map the docker
container to look at where the actual
project is going to be on your local
machine so we're going to create that
mapping and this is going to be/ custom
postgress and then uh from there we're
going to do the colon to create the
mapping to The Container path and then
the container path is simply just going
to be/ DBT which we've pointed right
here now we need to create another
volume here uh let me add a space here
because that requires a space uh we're
going to point to the um the DBT profile
that we did so we're going to need the
squiggly Tilda we need squiggly slbt and
we're going to point this over into the
root which is where we've pointed if I
could spell normally uh this is where
the profiles directory was which is
going to be in/ root so now we're
mapping our local TBT folder with the
profiles. emo file to the /root of the
docker container hopefully that makes a
bunch of sense cuz in my mind it kind of
does so we're also going to say depends
on the elore scripts we want DBT only to
run because remember when this container
starts we're running this command and if
we run DBT run on top of the destination
database without it having any data this
will not work because has nothing to
reference and it has nothing to write
data on so we need this to make sure
that it depends on the elt script and
the elt script depends on the two
databases so this is working down the
line we've essentially created a uh work
line here and then for the environments
we need two here so we need DBT profile
this one is going to be it's going to be
default and then we have another one
this one doesn't need a hyphen actually
cuz we made that mistake last time and
then we need DBT uncore Target and this
one is going to be Dev so this is going
to be everything we need for the DBT
container now all we need to do go ahead
and clear this I don't think compos down
Docker compose down everything uh I
think the volumes are still up but
that's totally fine so now we're going
to do Docker compose up did I type that
correctly H
C.I
DBT lab
DBT post press seven oh uh 1. 7 okay
that's another one another typo there we
go so we're going to go ahead and let
that run here so elt script exited Code
Zero so that's a good sign now the DBT
one should pop up invalid not a project
missing DBT project. file okay so
invalid project directory project
directory here custom post press maybe
we do not need this let's go ahead and
clear this let's do Docker down SLB and
then so maybe
custom oh I'm dumb uh it should have
been an underscore you can see all the
typos and everything really does make a
difference here so let's run that again
and that should map to the correct
project now hopefully there we go so
it's ran successfully I think unable to
do partial parsing encounted an error
error sources. runtime error
sources. list of actors film actors R
while parsing a block mapping uni code
okay so there was an error in our
sources file here somewhere that might
have been it um 13 and 14 film under
score actors okay let's do this one more
time I think my cat may have done
something with that so you can see there
a lot of back and forth here scripts ran
successfully okay it's taking a little
bit longer which is totally fine here
model fims was which was not found
there's a lot of typas going on film
ratings so if we go into Filmore rating
reference films fims okay here's the
typo let's talker compose down again so
also uh if you're curious if I'm Docker
composing down hyphen V I'm actually
killing the volumes every single time
just to make sure that everything is
working even if we're starting straight
from the beginning without any data
persisting so I'm that's the only reason
why I'm doing that um so now we Docker
compos up again this should work unless
I've made even more typos okay so we're
doing that again there we go okay so now
you can see that we've successfully run
our models so we've created a couple
models here the first one was the actors
the first one was the film actors the F
and the second or the third one was the
films so these are all our references so
we've successfully taken that in but now
we've actually done the fourth one which
is the model for the Filmore ratings so
you can see that that's actually worked
now now if we were to go and Docker
exact hyphen it and then I think it was
elt
destination or postgress hyph 1 and then
we do
psql hyphen U postgress so then we go
here we do c
destination DB we connect there and then
SLT so now you can see Filmore ratings
which is the new table that we've
written in DBT is actually written now
if we select all from Filmore ratings
and then with the semicolon you can see
that if I move this over it's a a little
big but you can see that our case has
gone in here uh it's kind of cut off
just because of the way that my terminal
looks you can see everything is in there
so we have our actors we have our film
ID we have the release date the price
but the most important part is the
rating that we've created here so the
case statement worked successfully so
anything above a 4.5 was excellent
anything below that between 4.0 and 4.4
was good and you had no average one so
you can see that we've actually created
this custom model successfully uh along
with the actor and the actor name so you
had Inception with Leonardo DiCaprio it
just looks a little weird because of the
way that um if I were to do this here so
let's do the same one so now you can see
it it it looks a well it still looks a
little weird but anyways you can see
that it works so that is creating a
simple model in DBT now let's look at
some other Advanced options you can do
inside of DBT to make your queries a
little bit more Dynamic is the best way
to put it okay so now that we've
actually created the models I told you
that we're going to get into some
advanced stuff with DBT and that's why I
mentioned the macros folder so you can
think of macros as sort of like a
reusable components of DBT where you may
have some sort of queries that you want
to reuse and is universal through pretty
much all your models so what if you
could just create a macro where you
didn't have to rewrite the same thing
every single time well you can
absolutely do that with macros let's
take the Filmore ratings file for
example let's say we wanted to generate
this every single time uh now that's
probably not going to happen but let's
say we wanted to do it and so let's just
go ahead and actually take the whole
file and cut it now inside of the macros
folder what we're going to create is
we're going to say Filmore ratings macro
do SQL file everything's going to be a
SQL file here now what we're going to do
is we're going to start the file with
curly bracket both sides are going to
have a parenthesis so double parenthesis
and inside that we're going to say macro
generate uncore Filmore ratings uh and
then we're going to parenthesis after
now the end of the macro is also going
to have curly brackets is also going to
have double parentheses but inside the
parentheses I'm sorry inside of the uh
percent signs you're going to say n
macro in one word now in between that is
where your macro is going to go so I'm
going to go ahead and paste what we just
took from film ratings into the macro
now Filmore ratings has nothing but if
we were to go inside of film ratings now
all we have to say is two early brackets
and we're going to call the generate
Filmore ratings macro so you can see
that this is the model that we're
actually writing and the macros never
actually gets written but if I were to
go back into our terminal here and let's
close this and let's say Docker compos
down I and V so let's kill the volumes
here we're going to say Docker compose
up and it's going to run through
everything all over again so let's go
ahead and let that go through really
quickly DBT is going to start running
and then there you can see we still have
four models being written if we go back
now over to the destination database uh
SLC destination _ DB and then /dt the
Filmore ratings table is still getting
written and if I do select all from
Filmore ratings you can see that we're
still writing exactly what we wrote in
Filmore ratings but we've only been
using the macro so you can see that
literally anything inside of the macro
file in between this section here and
here is going to be written exactly as
shown so if I were to say let's I don't
know let's create a a macro for this
case which probably is more plausible
than anything so if I wanted to say
generate
ratings macro SQL and we we wanted to do
the same thing where we go uh let's just
percent sign this generates ratings and
then we're going to end macro right and
then we paste this inside all we have to
do now is then just say generate ratings
call that and then we should be able to
do the same thing uh if we do this
Docker compose down B compose up let
that run again yes it takes a little bit
of time to run run it every single time
but you know this is just what it comes
with it be much harder is undefined
under undefined generate underscore
ratings it's not generate underscore
ratings uh it's generate uncore ratings
wondering if you can't call CT here so
now you can see kind of how macros could
work is it it allows you to have
reusable queries throughout your whole
DBT project essentially to just plug and
play in and not have to rewrite the same
thing every single time so if you have
reusable queries that you can use go
ahead and use macros because it's very
very efficient in terms of not having to
you know it it implores the dry method
of software engineering where you know
don't repeat yourself you don't have to
repeat yourself every single time if you
have the same queries over and over and
over again so utilize macros when you
can now let's move over into gingas
which is another feature of DBT okay so
this next section that I just mentioned
with gingas gingas are essentially what
allow you to create conditionals or add
control structures to your SQL queries
so for example that we're going to use
is let's say we wanted to select a
specific title but using a Ginga so we
didn't have to actually put it within
our actual SQL query that's what it
allows us to do it could allow you to
select you know do we want to use the
prod Target instead of the dev Target
inside of our DBT project then we could
do that as well and we can change the
way that queries are done again adding a
control structure so let's go ahead and
inside of our example folder we're going
to create a file called specific mov SQL
and inside of that is where we're going
to start with our Ginger here so again
starts with a curly brackets and then
two percent signs and inside of that
we're going to say sets so when you see
set this is essentially what is starting
our control structure here and we're
going to set Filmore title to equal for
this example we're going to say Dunkirk
cuz I know that's going to be a movie
inside of the demo or the um test
database here so Dunkirk is going to be
a movie that we're going to look for
right now inside of that we're going to
say select so this is the actual query
itself select all from and we're going
to reference the uh films table here
where let's practice here where title
equals and then we can say in the single
quotes
Filmore title so that is obviously the
variable that we've set up here right
that's going to be our Ginger here we're
setting a control structure where we
only want to select the title where
dynamically the value we've set here is
Dunkirk and obviously this can be
anything we want it to be but so let's
go ahead and save that and then run our
Docker compose up here and let
everything go when DBT runs we should
have a fifth model that runs which is
going to be our specific movie and so
let's go ahead and let that run here
there's going to be the fifth it's all
pass very good let's run our destination
database and SLC into it so
destination
db/dt and you can see specific movie is
now a table inside of this database and
so if I say select all from
specific movie you can see Dunkirk as
well as all of its information including
the film ID the release date price
rating and user rating is going to be in
there because we've used the Ginga in
there now it allows you to to pretty
much do anything you want you know if we
wanted to go into the macro here and
create conditionals where we have an
excellent condition a good condition or
an average condition and we set those to
be this number we can absolutely do that
and allows us to do that outside of the
query so that way we can know that up
here we can set it to a different movie
you know if we wanted to do Inception we
we're only changing it Inception pretty
sure that's how you spell it if it's not
that's going to be very awkward but so
let's do this Docker compose down V
Docker compose up let's run this again
and so when we run this we should see
that the specific movie has then changed
over to Inception instead of dunker
there therefore showing that the ginger
works and it it allows for a little bit
more readability right because you can
see that our film title we've set it to
a variable we're not you know manually
searching for a a movie here and then
we're going to do select all from a
specific movie and now you can see
Inception is now there so again a very
simple example of what a ginger is and
kind of how it works but go ahead and
play with it I implore you to kind of
you know inter integrate gingas with
macros to really really you know use the
full power of macros and gingas together
and I think it could really 10x your SQL
queries and your custom models from
within DBT and really just Excel that
process of the whole data engineering SL
data analytics process alog together
okay so as I've mentioned before we're
going to be adding a Cron job to this
not ideal I guess you could say in the
sense of that like it's not necessarily
the best implementation I guess you
could say but there are a lot of other
people out there that use Crown jobs I'm
going to show you the way you can
Implement a crown job because again you
don't want to manually be triggering
these data syncs or this pipeline to be
running on your own you kind of want
some automation here so the first thing
we're going to do is add the Cron job
I'll show you how you can do that in
this type of implementation obviously
there's different ways to implement it
but this will eventually evolve into US
adding a tool called airf flow airflow
is going to be an orchestration tool
that easily allow us to kind of have
more control than a Cron job over each
individual task inside of our project to
allow us to schedule it properly I think
the best thing that you can have is more
control outside of just scheduling when
it runs and so let me go ahead and show
you how the Cron job works first and
then we'll move into airflow and other
orchestration tools like that okay so
for the Cron job the main file we got to
go into is going to be the docker file
now because we're primarily M working on
the El script and we want to schedule
that this is where we're going to run
everything so just going to be some
slight modifications here so the one
thing we're going to do is we're going
to add KRON to the end of the list of
installs that we're going to do so we're
going to run for postgress client as
well as KRON underneath here now what
we're going to do is we're going to
create a new file called
start.sh now this is going to be a bash
script that we run so this sits in the
root directory and we'll modify this
later but above this copy script or
above this copy command that we have
we're going to add another one and this
one is going to be start.sh uh and we're
going to copy this over to the app
directory of Docker so that Docker now
has the start.sh file within its own
container here the working directory is
going to be the app so we're going to
say work is going to be slapp here in
between work directory and command this
is where we're going to add the crown
job now for this example we're going to
run the script let's say every day at
3:00 a.m. so we're going to do a run
command here and then we're going to
Echo and then in quotes we're going to
say zero space three and then three
asterisks and I'm sure there's like you
know sources online that can show you
kind of like how to properly write a
crown job for a specific time this is
just the one that I have now we're going
to say python SLA
slore script pi and then outside of that
we're going to do the divider here and
then we're going to say cron tab now
we're going to save this and then if we
go back into
start.sh this is where we're going to
write the uh to how to actually start
the Kon Damon so at the very top we're
going to say cron and and that pretty
much is what's going to run the KRON and
have it run in the background and then
python slapp
_ script.py what this is going to do is
we have the bash script and it's in our
working directory we're going to run
this command here when the docker
container starts and now this bash
script is going to run the pr in in the
background and then run this every
single time it's 3:00 a.m. and so we'll
run the bat scripts at 3:00 a.m. every
single time due to this Crown so again a
very simple implementation of how the
KRON is supposed to work obviously it's
hard to demonstrate this because it's
6:50 p.m. right now so I can't really
just wait here until 3: a.m. but now at
3:00 a.m. every single time this will
run so yeah that's essentially how this
Cron job is going to work now let's move
into how airflow is going to play in the
mix and how we can now orc rate this
using a real open source tool that's out
there in the wild all right so in this
section we're going to be adding airf
flow to our project and as I mentioned
before airflow is an orchestration tool
open source that allows you to
essentially have a top- down view of
every single task and say Hey I want my
elt script to run first and then once
this finishes and is
successful and that's exactly what we're
going to do here we're going to
orchestrate all of our tools and all of
the working pieces that we have right
now to make sure that they work
sequentially here and you know there's a
lot of different use cases with airflow
or other open source tools like Daxter
or prefect but we're simply going to be
using airflow as our orchestration tool
to make sure that our pipeline is
working the way we want it to and has
some form of automation here all right
so first thing we're going to do is
going to create a new folder here we're
going to name this airflow and inside of
airflow we're going to have another
folder called dags and a dag is simply a
directed ayylic graph I think is how you
pronounce the a part but so the dag is
what we write in order to orchestrate
all of our tasks together and also put
in some of our Logic for each task so
that's what we're going to be writing
here in DBT we were writing uh models
custom models in airflow we write dags
or in any orchestration tool we're going
to be writing a dag so that is another
term for you to put into your brain as
knowledge to know as a data engineer the
other thing we're also going to create
here is a file not inside of the dags
folder so this is going to go into the
root folder of airflow but this is going
to be airflow. CFG I think we just need
this for airflow specifically we don't
need to put anything in it but if you
needed to do anything with your
configuration of airf flow this is going
to be the file that you're going to put
it in now that we have this structure
put together let's go ahead and go into
our Docker compos file and then add the
airflow service this is going to be a
little extensive because it is a big
service so we're going to take our time
with this one and really go through it
all right so uh underneath the D B
section we're going to go here and add a
couple spaces because we're actually
going to be adding quite a bit of new
Services here that have to work with
airf flow it would be a lot but I've
narrowed it down to be very minimal here
so we don't have to worry about that too
much but the first thing we're actually
going to add is going to be another
postgress service and why are we adding
another postgress service here well it's
because airflow needs a database to
store its metadata and its logs so this
is the database that's going to go into
it's going to be the same look here
where we're going to say postgress and
the latest image here right um networks
we're going to tie into the
elcore network and then for the
environment let's do this so environment
we're going to do postgress user is
going to equal airflow here we have
postgress password which is going to
equal also airflow and then for the
postgress DB this is going to be airflow
so very simple there now fix this
now that's the metadata service so you
can name that whatever you want but I'm
for Simplicity sake I'm going to keep it
as postgress the next thing we need to
do is going to be an init airflow
service now for the init airflow service
what this is primarily doing here is
initializing the user and the database
that we just created all together for
airflow so we had we're going to add two
more services after this but this is a
very important service for us because
without this we're not going to have the
admin user and be able to create new
connections and things like that so this
is very important here now the image
that we're going to add is going to be
Apache so the Apache project open source
projects airflow and then latest this is
going to be the same for pretty much
every single uh I think it's going to be
the same for every single one but I
could be wrong U anyway so image this is
going to depend on postgress cuz we need
that database to be initialize
essentially before we initialize airflow
because without it we're going to have
some errors here networks again we're
going to say elore Network for the
environments we're going to say this is
going to be a long one so airflow
underscore uncore so twocor database _
SQL underscore alemy _ con for
connection is going to equal and this is
going to be pointing to our postgress
database here that we just created so
postgress
plusy cop G2 colon SL SL airflow for
username and password Here at postgress
SL airflow okay so that's that's a long
one but that's going to be the
environment there now last one we need
is a command the command we're going to
say uh less than or greater than sign
and in we're going to say bash iph C in
quotes airflow EB and nit to initialize
the database for airflow and and string
on another one here push it over here
and say airflow users create so we're
this is where we create the admin
account username airflow password is
going to be password let's just say
first first name is going to be John
last name is going to be do we want the
rooll here to be admin and then the
email we need to set let's say admin at
ample cool all right so that's a pretty
long one there already let's go down
here into the next service that we need
to create so that's our initialization
of air flow now we're going to get into
the actual like UI of airflow which is
going to be the web server service let
me add some spacing here the image we're
actually going to create a Docker file
for this so we need to do that first now
in the root of the directory here we're
going to say Docker file and then in
here we're going to say from Apache SL
airflow latest so the same thing that we
did uh with the initialization of airf
flow now we're going to say run tip
install Apache air flow providers Docker
now this is going to come in handy later
on but we do need this in order to run
this command here airflow has a bunch of
different providers for you to access
different Integrations Docker being one
of them and there's going to be another
couple ones that we're going to use
later down the line but Docker is the
one we need so now that we have this
we're going to go back into our Docker
compose file and then for the build
section we're going to say build context
just add the dot here the docker file
we're going to point to Docker file uh
just capitalize this part the US user
here is going to be root because we want
the root here and then it depends on the
postgress service so we do not want
airall to initialize until the metadata
store essentially is is initialized
networks we're going to point over to
the elt network and this is going to be
a special one here so extra hosts extra
hosts is going to be an interesting one
because we are running everything on
Docker we actually need this for special
reasons that'll come up later but so in
double quotes we're going to say host.
doer. internal and then we're actually
going to point that to host Gateway okay
so that points to inside Docker the host
Gateway so that's going to come in handy
later so now that we have that we're
going to point to some volumes here now
the volumes are going to be very
important so we have our dags that we
need to find So within that we're going
to say/ airflow SL dags so now we have
our dags folder now we need to map it so
we're going to map it to the slop slair
flow/ dags so now we have have the same
directory of dags inside the opt folder
and then it'll go to airflow dags so now
we have that inside of our Docker
container next one next one is going to
be the elt script that we have because
we need access to that
so/ is the folder that we have and then
we're going to say we're map that over
again to SL opt SL airflow SL elt so now
we have our own elt folder with the
script and all of its contents which is
just the bash script there now we need
the Transformations because we're also
going to be orchestrating not only the
script but we're also going to be
orchestrating DBT and we need access to
those files so we're going to say SL
custom hostress that is going to map
over to SL opt SL DBT now we have the
DBT folder in there we're going to need
the profiles for DBT so we're going to
say Tilda sl. DBT and then we're going
to point that over to SL root
sl. okay I hopefully this is all making
sense here this one is going to be
opening up essentially giving giv airf
flow access to the essentially the
docker Network so we this is going to be
very important here so we're going to
say /var run/ doer. sock we're giving
access to the socket there SL we MPP get
to SL SL run/ Docker okay cool now for
the environment variables and this is
going to get really long here so we're
going to get environment variables here
the first one is going to be load
underscore x = n these are all just
going to be needed for airflow exeggutor
equals local and we're we're going to
say airflow and we're mapping this back
to the database here so underscore
uncore database Alchemy con so I've uh
just copy and paste this over actually
cool so I've got that now one thing
airflow does need is it's going to need
a furnet key underscore fernet uncore
key so that's only one underscore there
and then we're going to say equals it
essentially encrypts the username and
password it's for security reason we're
just going to do that because you know
for the sake of this video so I've
actually if we go to orchest air flow I
have this command which I will also
leave for you in the description but
this is essentially going to generate
our fernet key for us and what we're
going to do is copy and paste that
command into our terminal and it should
spit out to us a key which we will then
use and paste here so now that is our
fit key that we're going to just leave
in and will be used for encryption sake
right and for security there's that uh
now we're going to need airflow
underscore uncore web server uncore
uncore default user underscore username
and that's just going to be airflow I'm
actually going to copy this and then
just change the last bit here to say
oops say password and this was going to
be password cool next environment
variable here we're going to go airflow
uncore 1core www uncore user underscore
username equals airflow same thing copy
and paste this password the last thing
we need is going to be
airflow web server
underscore secretor key that's just
going to be secret cool all right last
bits here we're going to say ports so we
need to expose the ports here uh this is
going to sit on P 8080 so we're going to
say 8080 here so that's how we're going
to access the web server and the command
we're going to run this web cool now the
one thing that's going to save us some
time here is we're going to copy and
duplicate the web server portion because
it's going to be the exact same but now
instead of web server this is going to
be the scheduler so it literally is
going to be the exact same so I don't
think we need to change anything no so
the scheduler is a needed worker for
airflow and so we absolutely need both
of these one the web server to give us a
UI to access and then we're also going
to need the scheduler to schedule all of
our jobs here and they're going to point
to the same exact thing okay so that is
going to be the setup for airflow now
let's go into writing our first dag in
order to actually orchestrate all of our
tasks here okay so we're going to go
into our dags folder here and we're
going to create a new folder and in that
folder is going to be
eltor dag dopy so we're going to be
writing some python now the first things
we're going to import are going to be
from date time import date time and time
Delta so we're going to be using some
time values here and the next one is
going to be obviously air flow so
airflow uh from air flow we're going to
import dag this is going to be a default
one that we're going to need because uh
obviously we need to type our dag from
Docker do types we're going to import
Mount this is going to come in handy for
us later because we're orchestrating
Docker services or Docker containers you
need some specific Docker types and then
you we also going to need a specific
Docker operator that comes from airflow
in order to actually orchestrate them uh
the next thing we're going to need is
going to be uh from airflow. operators.
python uncore operator we're going to
import the python
operator so this is going to be very
very crucial because our elt script is a
python script we need the python
operator in order to actually add that
in there okay so we're actually going to
copy and paste this down here as well
because in the same operator package
we're going to need the bash operator
we're going to change this to bash
operator so that way we can actually
interact with the bash here and and do a
couple commands there last one we're
going to do it's going to be from
airflow actually should be copy copying
this again so from there we're going to
say Docker underscore or I think it's
just docker here yeah just Docker and
then the docker operator cool so these
are all the packages oh actually we're
going to need one more sub process silly
me okay so those are going to be all the
packages that we need here now let's go
into some default arguments here so
we're going to see default uncore args
um this is just couple things so the
owner of this whole project here is
going to be airflow the next one is
going to be depends on past so do we
want this depends underscore onore past
we're going to say false on this so it
doesn't email on failure these are just
some things that are built into airflow
and we are setting some default values
here default arguments we're going to
say false and then
email onore
retry I think these should be curly
brackets not square brackets I screwed
up on that one cool all right now we're
going to write a function here Define
runor _ scripts so this is going to be a
function we use in order to actually run
the script now we're going to need the
script path obviously script scriptor
path we're going to set this variable
here and this is going to be pointed to
where we've set it inside of the docker
container so if you remember correctly
this path right here so we have opt airf
flow/ elt so we need to point to that
and not where it's pointed to locally
for us so we're going to say/ opt slair
flow sl/
_
script. Pi so now we're pointed directly
to the path of the elt script from
within the docker container so what we
can do now is we're going to say
result equals subprocess do run and this
is going to be you know we we've had
this command inside of actual batch
script itself so we're going to say
python we're going to run Python and
then we're going to use this point it to
the script path now after this we're
going to add a comma and we're going to
say capture output equals true so we
want to capture the output there and the
text equals true okay now after that
we're going to add a control structure
here so if
results. return code does not equal
doesn't equal zero that means we failed
something so we need to raise an
exception and in that we're going to say
script failed with error and then we're
going okay and then else we print the
result output cool now now let's
actually put this into a dag so we're
going to say dag equals and then point
it to the dag object that we just
imported add a parenthesis and this is
where we add in all the information so
the first one is going to be the name so
we're going to name it elore andore DBT
so that's going to be the name of our
dag now uh the default arguments this is
where it comes into play here so we're
going to say default arguments equals
the default arguments that we've
specified the description of this dag is
going to be an LT workflow with DBT
rhyming accidentally the start date
start underscore date is going to be
date time so that's where we're going to
use date time here and we're going to
say
2023 uh it the time of this recording is
currently October 28th so that's going
to be our start time there catch up is
going to be another one catch up equals
pulse we're we're not going to catch up
all right oh I didn't close it I'm done
so now we're going to go into actually
writing out the tasks so you can name
name a task whatever you want the first
thing I'm going to do or the easiest way
to do it for me is going to say T1 for
task one that's just the way I like to
do it and we're going to use the python
operator because the first task we want
is the elt script and because it is a
python script we need the python
operator now let's do the same thing
where we initiated the dag here where
we're going to add parentheses the task
ID is going to be task ID uh we're going
to tag this over and you know label this
as runor elt script so that we can
identify this properly we're going to
say python cable equals the Run elt
script function that we just created and
then the dag is going to equal dag okay
so very very simple we've we've given it
an identifier we've added the python
function here in order for us to
actually run the elt script and then
we've attached it to the dag that we've
created all right the next one is going
to be task two which is going to be DBT
and obviously for DBT we've added the
docker operator so let's go ahead and
add all the necessary information for
the docker operator the same thing is
going to be here so task uncore ID right
uh we're going to name this the same one
is going to be
DBT run very simple there after task ID
we're going to need to attach an image
to it and so um I we do have a DBT
container but we're actually going to
remove it and replace it with this so
we're going to do the same information
that we had in the the docker or the DBT
container so we're going to say GHC r.i
DBT lab DBT hen postgress for the
postgress adapter and then point it
directly to
1.4.7 all right and the command we're
going to run is going to be the exact
same so you can see kind of like the the
similarities here uh so we're going to
say that we're going to point it to the
profiles directory and the profiles
directory is going to be SL root the
project directory is going to be/ DT and
then that should be it the next one for
this one is auto remove so Auto remove
is do we want to automatically remove
the container once it's finished and
we're going to say true because we don't
want it open all the time so Docker URL
is going to be the next one and this
we're going to be pointing directly to
the the socket that we open so Unix sl/
bar/ run/ Doer
sock right it can identify where the
docker container is now the network mode
we're going to label as bridge and if
you remember the docker or the network
driver for the docker Network that we
had was a bridge so that is going to be
our mode here and then mounts so mounts
is going to be where we imported the
type of mounts this is where we're
actually doing the same thing that we
see here in the DBT service where we've
mounted these two volumes here and we
want to mount them because we're
actually doing exactly what we're doing
here but instead we're doing it inside
of airflow we're creating this Docker
container from scratch using the same
information but that way airflow has
sight of okay well this is exactly what
I'm orchestrating let me go ahead and
create this and then run it so the first
thing we're going to do is say Mount and
then inside of that is going to be
Source the source of this is going to be
the local path of my actual custom
postgress so I'm going to say users SL
my name is Jus Chow slev development and
this is going to be separate and a very
different uh depending on what you're
doing here so the inside of development
is just the elt folder and then we're
going to go into
custom press is where my source is now
after this we're going to say Target
equals slash in single quotes SL DBT
well that's
essentially mapping the source to the/
DVT folder and we're going to say type
equals bind okay now what we're going to
do is we're going to copy this and we're
going to add a comma here now this is
going to be shorter here so I can get
rid of pretty much everything here and
then we're going to say DBT because this
is our profile and then instead of
Target being SL DBT we want this to be
root and the type is going to remain
bind the last thing we need after the
mount is going to tag it to the dag so
dag dag and there we go that's pretty
much writing both of our tasks the last
thing we need to do here is create the
order in which we want it to run and so
at the very bottom here we're going to
say T1 2 greater than signs and then T2
so this means that T1 takes priority
over T2 and that's the order that we
want it to run in okay so let's go ahead
and make sure to save this it looks like
we have that's fine we don't have to
worry about this so that is pretty much
writing our dag here let's go over it
one more time we've created some default
arguments here that airflow needs inside
of the dag we've created our python
function in order to correctly identify
where the script is and then we're going
to go ahead and run it with some error
checks here we've created the actual dag
itself and named it with the default
arguments description and then the start
time we've created the first task here
using the python operator giving it an
identifier pointed the function we
created to it so that's what we know to
run and then we've attached it to the
dag we created and then this is the
second operator or the second task here
using the docker operator and
essentially creating DBT in a new
container and then running and mounting
everything we need to correctly have you
know the DBT project run on top of the
destination once the first task has run
and then we've created the order of
operations here which we wanted to run
so hopefully this all makes sense and
this next one we're going to go ahead
and run it and show you what the web
server looks like and then make sure
that the dag actually works so let's get
into that okay so we have our dag now
the one thing to note is that we are
actually running this script here and
then creating a new Docker container
here for TBT so we can actually go back
into our Docker compos file and we're
going to comment out the DBT as well as
the elt script containers because we do
not need to create them anymore because
we have airf flow doing it we don't need
to have them anymore so let's go ahead
and comment those out and what we're
actually going to do is we're going to
do Docker compose up and run all these
containers so I forgot to do one thing
so remove the port section and then the
command should be scheduler not web
server that's my bad so let's do Docker
compose up again ports must
exist there we go okay just some weird
issue there so this is airflow
initializing everything everything seems
to be going into plan here and so now we
can do exit with Code Zero we should see
the scheduler and the web server pop up
in just a second here oh you know what
okay so now that we have everything
going let's go ahead and create all of
our Docker compos files so but the first
thing we have to do is actually run the
init airflow container first because
it's very important so we're going to
say Docker compose up init hyphen
airflow and we're going to actually say
iph d in order to do that first so what
that's going to do is going to start the
postgress and it's going to start the
ini initialize airflow containers first
and if we go to Docker desktop here you
can see that they they're already
running we actually need those to be
running first before we enable anything
else because without those the web
server and the scheduler will not work
so now what we can do is we're going to
say Docker compose up and that's going
to create the rest of the docker
containers that we have and so let's go
ahead and wait for that now we can see
that the web server is now open so what
I'm going to do here is going to do open
a new window and then we're going to go
to Local Host and remember we said 80 80
so if we go to Local Host 8080 we are
now in the airflow UI so airflow
password was the username and password
that we enabled here we're going to say
no here no but you can see we have an
issue opt airflow dags
_
D.P a broken dag so that's fine I think
what we probably forgot to do was
install the python operators so let's go
ahead and debug this really quickly a
nothing like a little bit of problem
right so let's just make sure op airflow
do oper python oper oh so this should be
an operator not operators now let's go
ahead and go back and kill all of these
again so Docker compose
down B we're going to say the same thing
so we're going to say Docker Air B let
that run for a second and then kner goes
up okay let's go back to our web server
here should load up in just a second go
airflow
password in I may have tried a little
too soon there we go uh we're still
running into an error here docker's the
operator I think I probably did this
let's look at the docker file here tip
install Apache High airflow High
dock okay so I found the issue it was
from the actual package here so I wasn't
doing it properly on the docker file
here Apache airflow providers Docker so
this should actually be airflow.
providers. doer uh and then operators.
doer so that should be the import name
uh that's why we were getting the issue
here uh so we're going to say Docker
composed down B do the same thing here
end then airflow wait a couple seconds
then docker compos up in a second now
hopefully this should fix the issue
because I had another just like simple
typo so if we go back now crash airflow
password still the same issue oh I had
it twice it's another typo okay so this
shouldn't be operators this should be
providers A okay
compose down I B doer initialize it
again doer compose up again just some
simple simple typos that are screwing it
all up there we go now now that I
haven't typoed anything you can see that
we have the elt and DBT dag here we have
the owner being airflow we have all the
runs um so you have failed running
success cued you have a schedule your
last run next run which we pointed out
would be today but we're going to go
ahead and manually run this so what
we're going to do is actually going to
trigger the dag and what we're going to
see here is we're going to see it run so
we see one is one is uh still cued so we
have one successful and I believe we
should be waiting for one more to go
believe we're still waiting for one more
to go yeah okay so we see one has failed
now let's go ahead and check why um so
the dbt1 failed DBT was not running at
the state so we can check the logs here
now remember that we created that DBT or
sorry that postgress service for the
airflow and so that is because of this
so we needed the actual postgress
database for this reason so we can
actually get some logs here if you
didn't have it it wouldn't we wouldn't
get any logs here so it's actually
erroring out because custom post. myc
DBT model depends on a node name my
first DBT model which was not found
which is interesting because this is not
what we had in mind here very
interesting so it looks like the script
worked but the DBT section did not so
we're going to have to take a look at
why and it has to be something in here
right so the DVT run profiles directory
profiles directory is going be /root
project directory is going to be/ DVD if
we check the docker desktop we go into
web server go into files here um and
then I believe so root should contain
our DBT folder with the profiles. yl
folder and we can actually see that
custom poost press has exactly the
information we're looking for so that's
roots that is fine the other one that we
should have airflow yeah EGS no air
where did we put the actual put in/ DBT
so let's go back this should be in a DBT
but it is not SL op /d and I believe our
models should be in here okay so I think
we're pointing it to the wrong area here
so SL opt SL DBT let's go ahead and see
if that changed everything cuz we didn't
create the Ste section there so let's go
ahead and restart this so we're going to
say
airflow wait a
second okay let's go back to the UI
password okay this is still going let's
go ahead and Trigger it okay I think
we're still waiting on one one's running
right now which is a good thing let's
hope it doesn't fail fails now let's go
ahead and Che the logs here here invalid
project directory not a project project
AML okay so that's a better sign which
means that we just need to change this
now SL
op SL now I believe that when we run
this it should work let's go ahead and
kill this same
thing close up should be good reset go
Ahad and run it so looks like the elt1
ran successfully and then we're just
going to wait for the second one to pass
hopefully it does and it's still failing
why is it still pointing to the other
models I don't know how this happened
but inside of the example folder there
was a my second DBT model sequel file
that was throwing the error so I just
deleted it so now let's try and see if I
don't know how that got in there I I
don't even remember if I deleted it or
not but obviously while we were testing
it manually it wasn't throwing an error
but now airflow decides to throw the air
let's go ahead and see if that's going
to fix the issue I'm pretty sure it will
very just like didn't even think about
it kind of thing but again like I'm
leaving all these mistakes in there not
because it's like obviously doesn't look
that great but I do believe that these
errors are just a part of Engineering in
general and so I think it's good to put
some light on it and just you know not
every course or not every lesson is
going to be fully fledged I think it's
better to just leave that stuff in there
because you know we all go through
mistakes stuff like this happens where
it just you know there was one file that
was throwing everything off or something
like that now let's go ahead and see if
I can actually get in here so I can
refresh and I'm in so let me go ahead
and hit start on the dag and let's see
what we get here so it looks like our
batch script worked now we're just
waiting for airflow let's hope for a
number two on the green I think we're
still running cool that was it that was
literally it so now you can see we have
two on the success part so we have our
DBT and our elt script that ran
successfully so what we can do now is we
can go into our destination post Crest
and do the
destination
DB and we're going to say /dt and you
can see all the models and everything
that we ran are now inside of the
destination
and to prove that I can say select all
from uh let's say specific movie again
and you can see that the Inception
selection is still there I can say
select all from users and everything
should be in there so that is
successfully adding airflow with some
minor hiccups but obviously you can see
here that our python operator and our
Docker operator are in play here and
working it does take a little bit of
work to make sure that everything is
moving because they yes there is a lot
of moving Parts here but in this next
section with the elt script we're making
it a lot easier because we're removing
the need for the elt script we're
actually adding in another open source
tool that I happen to work for called
air bites to be able to add more
Integrations and more data sources more
destinations with ease so let's look at
how that would work with orchestration
and everything like that all put
together now all right so for this next
and final section like I mentioned we're
going to be implementing an open-source
data integration tool called airite
which I just so happen to work for
airite we are pretty much a data
Movement platform like I just said so
you have a bunch of sources like we have
our source database and we have our
destination database both in postgress
now imagine you have a couple other
sources that aren't just postgress but
you also have places like Salesforce or
LinkedIn Facebook marketing places like
that where you need data to come out of
and then move them into you know your
destination postest data base or you may
have some cloud data warehouses things
like that airite is the platform to
easily sync all of them together without
having to manage any of these manual
scripts like the one we just made use a
dump file to go from postgress to
postgress uh it would be much more
complicated if we were doing that from
you know a different source to a
different destination and so I'm going
to show you how easy it is to get air
bite into your project and it's open
source like I said and utilizes Docker
so it's pretty easy to hook up to the
rest of our application and then get
airf flow hooked up as well so let's go
ahead and do that so I am on the air
bite repo right now which you can just
go on GitHub and all we're going to do
pretty simply is just copy this uh what
we're going to do is we're going to go
back into our terminal here we're going
to stop all of the docker containers and
then what we're going to do is get clone
and then we're going to clone air bite
into our repo here so that's going to
take a little bit the big open source
package and then if you want it to read
the read me on how to get started and
things like that all of it is down here
but you can see that literally like you
can use this project for free and that's
the beauty of Open Source right so now
if we hit LS you can see we've created
an airite directory here and if we open
our project here on vs code you can see
that airite is now successfully inside
of the file directory along with
everything else so now let's hook up
everything together to make sure that it
works in harmony so before we run
anything with air bite we actually got
to set up a couple things so we do not
need to touch this Docker compos file
anymore that is completely all set and
ready to go if we go into this Docker
file you can see that obviously we've
installed the docker provider we're
actually going to install the air bite
provider as well as a couple other
things uh yes like I mentioned that
there are a couple other Integrations
with airf flow and air bite is one of
them with open source it's a little
different but we do use the HTTP
provider as well as the air bite
provider so we're going to change this
command up a little bit everything's
going to stay the same but when we run
pip install the provider's docker we're
going to add a little uh Slash here
we're going to say and and tip
install Apache
airflow providers and then we're going
to say HTTP we're going add another
backs slash here and we're going to add
another and and and then this is going
to be pip install Apache airflow
providers air bite so now we're
installing three different packages that
we need uh I mean yes we do we do need
the docker one still but so yes we we're
going to be using airflow for Docker
HTTP and air bite works anonymously
together HTTP provider is a dependency
for the air bite provider so now we're
going to save that and I'm actually
going to change up this
start.sh file so it's going to make it a
little bit easier to run the whole
project Al together we don't have to
keep waiting for the init air flow to
start and then we can kind of structure
the way that all these Zer containers
are running with this bash script so let
me go ahead and do that right now okay
so we're going to actually delete all
this stuff that's in here right now the
first thing that we want to do is we
want to do Docker compose up and then we
want to do init airflow now that's going
to obviously do the initialization of
air flow after that we're going to wait
5 seconds so we're going to sleep the
command for 5 seconds and then next
we're going to say Docker compose up I
and D to run it in the background
because if we don't run in the
background we can't really um continue
to see air bite come through so after
that we're going to sleep for another 5
seconds after that we're going to change
directories into the air bite directory
because if we see it here you can well
you don't you won't see it now but there
is a Docker compos file that needs to be
downloaded here and that's exactly what
we're going to do so we're going to CD
into air bite and we're going to do a
little check here because the way that
we run it is there's a run platform uh
shell script that we need to run with
air bite and that is the initialization
where it downloads all the correct files
that we need to in order to spin up all
the docker containers so we're going to
say if and we're going to look for the
file here so we're going to say uh
hyphen f and then we're looking for
docker
compose yl that's the file we're looking
for if that exists then we're going to
uh run Docker compos up hyphen D if it
doesn't exist we're going to run slash
run hyphen ab
platform.sh and then we're going to
finish okay so very simple script here
uh we're also going to create another
one that's going to say stop. sh so this
one is going to say Docker compose down
I hyphen V and then we're going to uh I
think we're going to sleep for 5 seconds
we're going to CD into air bite and and
then do Docker compose down so that is
going to be the start and stop for this
to make this easier to run every single
container so now what we're going to do
we're going to go into our dag and then
change up everything because we no
longer need this elt script obviously
going to still need the docker operator
but the python operator we don't need it
anymore since we're going to be using
air bite to do it so let's go ahead and
hook that up right now all right so like
I said we we actually didn't end up
using the bash operator and we don't
need the python operator anymore so we
can remove this um let's go ahead and
remove the time Delta as well because we
do not need that right now so what we're
going to do is also remove this function
here and then this is what we're going
to start doing our actually I'm going to
leave this for now so right here above
the default ARS we're going to create a
Conor ID a variable and this is going to
be a string so this will make sense so a
connection ID is what this stands for
within airite we have a connection ID
and a workspace ID and those are just
identifiers for your specific instance
of airite let's say but more
specifically if we're looking at the
source and the destination that we
currently have the both of the postgress
databases connecting those together
obviously create a connection and for
airite when we connect the to we have a
connector and that connector has that
connection ID so that's exactly what
we're going to use variable for is to
grab that and then input it here into
the dag to make sure that we're
orchestrating the correct connector
right now and so here what we're going
to do is we're actually going to go back
up here we're going to say from airflow
uh the first thing we're actually going
to do is from utils and dates so we're
going to use the dates util from airflow
we're going to import days uncore ago
under that we're going to say from
airflow uh. providers do air. operators.
air we're going to import the airite
trigger sync operator so this is going
to be the module that we're using to
trigger syncs on the connection that we
create with from within airbag now we're
going to replace that replace T1 with
this operator here let's go ahead and
replace it and now the first thing we're
going to do is change the task ID so
this is uh oh whoops I replaced the
wrong one uh this is the python operator
we're trying to replace so the first
thing we're going to replace is the task
ID so this one is going to be the Airy
postgress _ postgress task ID and uh we
no longer have a python callable here
but the first thing we're going to do is
aircore Conor ID which is an argument
that we need which obviously we've
provided which is going to be airite so
this will make more sense once we're
inside of webflow but we need to make a
connection inside airf flow and we're
going to name that air bite so we're
going to add that the connection ID is
what we provided so this will point to
the con ID variable that we had right
make sure that my com here underneath
that is asynchronous so if we wanted to
asynchronously do jobs asynchronous I
think is how I spelled it wait did I
spell that right asynchronous false so
this is not going to be asynchronous we
would have to add another operator but
we're not doing any jobs asynchronously
we're only triggering one job so we're
going to leave it at that we're going to
leave the timeout to 3600 we're going to
say waitor seconds uh we're going to
wait 3 seconds and then the dag
obviously we're we're putting back into
dck so you can see pretty simple in
terms of what it's accept here the main
thing here to note is going to be these
two properties right here so the airb
con ID which we're going to find within
airflow and then the connection ID is
going to be what's important to us here
so we're actually going to save that and
nothing else changes so we've we've
successfully put an airbyte within the
dag um the one thing we need to do here
is we do need to add our connection ID
which we have not gotten yet there is a
little bit of a trick here that we're
going to have to do um it's kind of
inefficient but for the sake of this
project we're going to have to do it so
let me show you what that is we're going
to have to make another bash script
potentially but it should all be okay
this is what happens when you kind of
have to work with multiple different
Docker containers since air bite is
working in in its own so let's go ahead
and do that right now I'm actually going
to create another bash script here um
this one's going to be el. sh and this
one is going to be exactly what we did
before where it's just Docker compos up
and knit hyphen airflow and then we're
going to sleep for five and then we're
going to Docker compose up Hy so the
reason for this is that airite has its
own set of Docker containers that are
running to make sure that everything is
working and then we have our own El
containers that we've already been
working with and we can close those
separately now in order for this to work
we need to grab the connection ID that
we make from within air bite and in
order to create the connection we need
to obviously hook up the source and the
destination together which we're going
to do next but then when we have the
connection ID we can't necessarily save
the connection ID in into the dag and
then you know load it up we're going to
have to kill the container so that the
new connector ID propagates but airite
will still be active so we're just going
to go ahead and kind of go through that
process but then at the end we'll see
that airflow is able to read everything
that we've done and then we can
orchestrate both airbit that's replacing
our elt script and then using DBT to
write on top of the destination
databases that we have currently so
let's go ahead and run air bite right
now and then we'll get going into uh
hook up both of the source and
destinations to create our first
connector all right so now we're in the
UI and then now all we got to do is put
in our information here you can choose
this if you want but I'm going to say
get started and then now we're in the
airb UI and let me walk you through
really quickly it's it's very simple so
we have connections so if you have all
your sources and destinations and
they're connected together this would be
your connections if we go to sources you
can see we have a bunch of different
sources both certified as well as
community and the same thing on the
destination side so the one thing we're
going to do is we're actually going to
go for postgress here you can see it's
pretty simple and it's just simply
logging in to your instances here or our
databases so I'm actually going to name
this source postgress and then for the
host here we're going to say host. doer.
internal and for the port I believe Port
5433 is is the name or is the port
number and then for the database name is
going to be Source DB now for the
username was just postgress and for the
password was just secret okay now no SSL
modes no SSH tunnels needed for this
sake I'm going to be using detect
changes with the X-Men system column and
then you know if you have any jdbc URL
parameters here you can absolutely add
that let me go ahead and hit setup
Source here and then it should just
essentially make a call to the postest
database there through the API and We're
Off to the Races it should just connect
properly if everything is correct and if
I look on Docker we should have the
containers open so that is correct
correct cool all the test connections
have passed so then it spits us over to
create a connection and we're actually
going to add a destination now which is
going to be also postgress now it's
going to be the same thing we're going
to name this destination
postgress uh host. doer. internal the
port here is going to be 5434 DB name is
going to be destination DB default
schema uh we're going to name the user
postgress and then it's kind of hidden
right now but in the optional Fields
we're going to say secret as the
password because we do need that and
then we're going to go ahead and hit
setup destination and cool all test
connections have passed and what you can
see up here uh is that we have you know
the connection name we have source
postgress to destination postgress
replication frequency there is an
orchestrator from within airite but we
want to switch this over to manual
because we are orchestrating this with
airf flow if we were wanted to just have
this work on its own we can absolutely
do that if we wanted to add a Cron job
you can absolutely do that as well from
within here but for our sake we're going
to use manual there's a name space
there's the stream prefix to identify
streams a little easier and here is all
the tables coming in from our source
database now what I'm going to do here
is I'm going to check all of these cuz I
want all of these streams or all of
these tables to come with and now from
here we can choose a sync mode so do we
want to fully refresh every single time
do we want to incremental which we
recommend uh only the changes because it
does support CDC do we only want to sync
the changes from the database over to
the destination depending on the
transactions uh in our case we're going
to do full refresh overwrite for all of
them uh so we can do some uh testing
here but uh yes incremental sync is
probably the way to go here we do offer
normalized tabular data in this so we do
some normalization on top of the data
and that is totally fine so I'm going to
go ahead and set up this connection here
and there there we go uh once this is
all set up we can see here at the top we
have a couple IDs that are very
important to us so the first one is
going to be the workspaces ID uh the
next one is going to be the connections
ID we want this connections ID so what
we're going to do is copy this head over
into our dag and paste this into the
connection I now we're going to save
this but remember what I said when we uh
you know when we launch airflow and and
all of these containers right here
they're in separate instances right and
so the change I just made has not
propagated and so we're not going to be
able to stop or to start the dag right
now so what we're going to do is we're
actually going to kill the elt section
first and then leave airite open restart
this we should be able to then start the
sink using airflow so what I'm going to
do now is Docker compose up or uh we
have that e T script so what I'm going
to do is I have to add uh chod plus
x/t Dosh and now I can say elt
Dosh and that should run the init first
and then that should run the rest of the
docker containers we need on the elt
side um so the init is done and we can
see it down here and then it should
follow up with all of that so there we
go everything should be initialized now
what we have to do is obviously
everybody is still running now let's go
in and do Local Host port 8080 so that's
going to let us sign into our instance
here uh we're having an issue with the
dag uh I think it's the provider here
yep okay so I had this issue with this
before airflow. providers. a. operators.
airb um let me double check to make sure
that is the correct installation of it
so where we're probably going to need to
do is for some reason this doesn't fully
work work here user airflow yeah because
we let me double check this um oh I
forgot to do that okay so the one thing
we do actually need to do is we need to
remove this user tag here because we
want the user to switch every single
time so uh we it's a weird thing where
you have to be the airflow user before
to install the actual correct operator
and then switch back to the route in
order to run the dag so that's what
we're going to do we're going to do
Docker compose down hyphen B
um and then run our El script again
after we remove that so let's go ahead
and run it should be good so then it
will use it'll go down and read the user
airfow first run this command to install
all the correct operators and then we'll
have back to the user route once they're
installed that way we can actually run
the dag okay so that should be good let
me go ahead and wait for it to run here
there we go uh still having an error
here all right so I got it working and
this is just a note uh there is some
weird issues kind of with Docker but so
if you you ever run into issues like
that you want to go into the images
section so I had to look for the elt web
server and scheduler because we built
those images already and it doesn't
propagate with these new commands here
and so when I reran or sorry when I
deleted the images and reran it it
actually went through and installed the
correct operator so now if we go back to
the web UI you can see that the dag is
now in there so we did everything
correctly it was just a matter of
deleting the images on Docker first and
so now what we're going to do
is before we even run it we need to go
up into connections uh and then hit this
plus sign right here and now what we can
see is we have a connection type of air
bite but that's not exactly what we're
going to be using so if you remember
this connection ID if we go back to the
code of the dag you can see we had a
connection ID of airb so what we're
going to do is we're going to say air
bites we're going to go down into HTTP
and then for the host is going to be do
uh host. doer. internal we don't need to
provide login password but for the UI
we're actually going to point it to 801
because that's going to be where um we
can access the actual UI and everything
so we're going to hit save and so now we
have this air bite section if we go back
to dags let's go ahead and Trigger this
and so we triggered it if we go back to
the airb connections we should be able
to refresh and hopefully see that a
stream is going to start here eventually
okay so it failed instantly okay so it
looks like it errored because let's
actually go back to the uh the
connections here we actually may need to
do a login password so this is host.
doer. internal 801 let's add airite and
password because this is a default um
thing that's needed or login that's
needed for us on our side uh for
security reasons and obviously that can
change let me go ahead and rerun this
again and that should give us
permissions to run the sync there we go
so now you can see that we have a sync
running so we've able to trigger the
actual sync Now using airflow and that
should just work so if we go back to
statuses here we should be able to watch
it go and then once that's loaded into
the destination then the DBT container
will spin up and then we will have all
of our models written onto the
destination side but data was moved from
airbit so let's go ahead and wait for
that to load here but if we go back to
the dags we can see that it's all
working now we were able to successfully
connect to airbit and it's not going to
succeed until this is completely done
there we go so sink has succeeded you
can see that we have 113 records
extracted if we go back to airflow we
should be able to see that it will
succeed and then it's going to run DBT
uh there we go so there's the first
success and then now we're waiting for
DBT to run and then once DBT has run
we're going to go ahead and check so DBT
just successfully ran go back into our
terminal and then go back into our
destination database so see
destination DB let's go ahead and do a/
DT and then you can see so now we have
some extra stuff so you can see airb
actually wrote some raw data into the
database but it has come with all of the
other tables here notice how specific
movie and film ratings isn't here so you
can see that DBT actually ran we only
have the tables coming from the source
database and now if we do select all
from specific
movie that's going to show the actual
Inception you know all that stuff along
with some airite metadata so you could
see that has actually successfully
worked we have air B being orchestrated
by airf flow and DBT now being
orchestrated by airflow all within this
simple project and that right there is
the full project completed hopefully
that give you a pretty high level
understanding and example of how you
could successfully create a data
pipeline from scratch but then
ultimately lead that into a
fully-fledged open-source data pipeline
where you're sending data from a
postgress database using a tool like
airite to connect it to a destination
datab base where you need the data to go
to and then from there you're
orchestrating it with airflow writing
custom models on top of it with DBT to
then use for other sort of data analysis
or things like that ultimately the
destination could be anything where it
ends up in a CRM or some sort of tool
like metabase or looker for other open-
source options there but essentially
this is kind of like my version of a
storytelling where you can see how a
data pipeline can evolve how complicated
it can be at the very beginning but then
how simple it can be at the very end
when you start using some of the tool in
the modern data stack where you know you
have tools like air bite and airflow and
many other tools where you can bring
into the stack and just make it a lot
easier as a data engineer now the
opportunities here are endless and this
is can hopefully open some doors to you
to test some things and also play around
with other things to become a data
engineer eventually but please let us
know how we did please let me know if
you have any questions or if you learned
anything new here please let me know
down in the comments or anything like
that but I hope you all enjoyed this
course and thank you so much for
watching